Sweet baby jesus.
We are back again.
Ah,
ah.
Satisfaction relief,
tension fulfilled,
fulfilled,
exploded,
whatever.
Listen,
San Diego,
you fucking savages were off the chain this weekend.
I want to thank the fuck out of every one of you.
It was amazing that that was a one of my favorite shows ever in San Diego.
Even with hecklers,
it was great.
It was just a couple of douchebags.
Somebody boot,
Joey [inaudible],
Joey Diaz.
When he got on stage.
I think it's the same guy who heckled me later.
He yelled out,
boom,
sure.
It's just some,
some port duty.
Probably if you signed up for the army when he was 18 something.
There's a lot of those down there,
but the audience was fucking incredible.
It's just got,
damn.
I love San Diego.
That is a,
that is what one of the most underrated all time cities.
It really is placed incredible.
Further,
we'd fear,
well,
it's because of the military thing.
I mean they definitely have an issue with with marijuana down there.
They shut down all the shops.
It's fucking,
there's military everywhere down there.
It's crazy if you have military and weed because then they start getting high
and going,
let's just run to Mexico,
man.
It's right there.
Let's just fucking,
let's get outta here.
Fuck this dude.
I don't want to shoot anybody anymore anyway.
Uh,
thanks everybody.
Fuck a fantastic show this weekend.
Montreal sold out.
Bitches suck at no tickets.
Tough Shit.
You always sell out in Canada.
You should probably just get super big.
I should probably just move there as well.
I should probably do.
Canada is fucking awesome.
Um,
even in November in Montreal with the Duncan Trussell,
we are going to be there and eventually see George Saint Pierre going to fight
Carlos condit.
Oh shit son.
What a wild weekend that will be.
Um,
this podcast ladies gentlemen,
it's brought to you by taking one of our newest sponsors and what Ting is,
ladies and gentlemen is a fair and ethical mobile company.
What do I mean by that?
They don't have all the goofy fucking laws or rules rather set in place by a lot
of these cell phone companies,
especially the one that really bites my ass.
And that's the one we have to pay money.
If you want to cancel your contract.
That shit to me is ridiculous.
That's like going to the supermarket and saying,
I want to buy milk,
and them saying,
well,
if you want milk,
you got to pay for your milk every day and when you no longer want to pay milk
for milk,
we have to get some extra money from you.
That's how I look at it.
I don't look at cell phone services,
any other kind of,
I as a good,
you're,
you're selling goods just like you're selling milk to me,
maybe in my logic is faulty and if,
look,
if you were smart,
don't get me wrong,
and you were sitting here and you wanted to argue that point with me,
you'd probably win.
But my point is it doesn't make any sense.
I know why they do it,
whether the way,
the reason why they do it,
it's kind of tricky.
Like when you buy a cell phone from Verizon and it's as 300 bucks,
it's the phone cost more than 300 bucks.
So they sort of tacked that money onto your bill and then if you tried to cancel
early,
then you have to like make up the difference and pay for what the phone really
would have been like.
Phones,
like a good iPhone or something that's really fucking expect 600 to $700.
Tim doesn't have that set up.
The way [inaudible] works is you want to cancel,
just fucking cancel.
If you don't use all your minutes,
like say if you have a higher,
um,
plan with more minutes and you don't use it,
they automatically bump you down to the next plan and your next bill and save
you money.
Like it is a very,
very fair and ethical company and they work off this sprint backbone so they
have excellent cell phone service.
Joey Diaz,
a sprint that sprint for years.
If you try to take sprint away from Joey Diaz,
who will fucking stab you fucking sprint cock sucking my shit never goes.
I can make calls from the fucking plane in the air.
You've got a phone call on the air ones.
I Dunno how he did it,
but we were sitting there and his fucking phone Joe,
he never turns his phone off.
You know how they say turn your phone off on a plane?
He's never turned it off.
Once he doesn't do it.
I always try to like turn it on like about 20 minutes before you land and see if
I can get service.
A lot of times you can,
well yeah,
a lot of times it's planes crashing.
People died.
You have fuck you fucking techno Weirdo,
but a rogan.ting.com they will give you $50 off of your first ting device and
the devices are all top of the line.
They have a bunch of sick fuck an android phones,
including the one that I have,
the Samsung Galaxy three which I love and I have raved about this phone.
It is very hard to go back to an iPhone after you see that big giant,
luscious Samsung Galaxy s three screen.
And by the way,
they just outsold a iPhone for the first time ever.
So the galaxy s three right now is the number one selling cell phone in America.
Why?
Yeah,
because
the Chinese can't make the iPhone five [inaudible].
They're rioting.
That's what it is.
I know it.
That's a true,
oh,
I would tell the truth,
man looks at Samsung did get that official lead though.
You know what I'm saying?
It's like when James Irv and blew out his knee is because they use American
workers,
right,
Joe?
Exactly.
No,
they don't.
No.
I don't know if there's an ethical cell phone to buy folks.
There's certain shit in this day and age you're going to have to ignore unless
you get a cell phone.
Maynard Montana had a fucking deer antlers and old scrap.
I think they fucking sell shit.
I just pay for one of these tings.
Phones.
Should I just not wait for these guys?
Go obviously not.
You know,
listening to him,
they were like down with the Wikipedia.
We wiki people were [inaudible] people do not want to recognize Brian red band
as an official celebrity,
and I say that's bullshit because they recognize a lot of people that are less
famous.
Porn stars,
every single porn stars in there.
Is there something about the day or not accepting this medium,
and this is a you fuck heads,
better comp color.
Correct.
This is a legitimate medium.
This internet business.
I was in the,
in the newspapers and newspaper sort of.
It looks like Doug's Doug and to me,
but you know,
whatever buddy.
I'm sure they printed.
It's like a missing child.
Have you seen this boy
when he went down to Tijuana to buy valiums and we never saw him again?
Um,
anyway,
go to rogan.ting.com that's our sponsor on it.com was one of ours,
other sponsors on it.
It's got a bunch of new shit in folks.
We finally got that.
We were selling that video that I used to talk about even back in the day before
on it,
the extreme kettlebell cardio workout.
We started selling that.
It's amazing.
We also started selling Blendtec blenders,
which I just started using a couple of weeks ago.
I used to use a Vitamix,
which is bad ass.
It's a very good blender,
but the BLENDTEC is even better.
It's incredible how much it just liquefies everything.
It's the most amazing blender that I've ever,
ever used.
We were selling it and give it away.
Free hemp force protein powders,
but Blendtec won't let us do that anymore.
It's like a violation of the cars.
We sell it really cheap anyway.
Yeah,
we sell it for $200 less,
more than $200 less than the manufactured suggested retail price.
You can't sell that cause then the competitors,
they don't have that advantage of and the free hemp force giveaway a free him.
We should do.
You should have a coupon code that if you happen to buy a blender,
you can put this coupon code in.
It adds it for you.
So it's,
you're not selling it with it.
Yeah.
I still think that's loophole.
We sell it as maybe look at you.
What do you marketing genius.
Yes.
There's loopholes.
She's going to get a suit this fuck.
He doesn't even care.
Hemp for us,
uh,
is another product of on it.
And uh,
I had some this morning,
most delicious protein powder on earth.
It's made out of the everything at on.
It is what an honor.
It is like essentially a supplement company,
health nutrition,
fitness company.
Everything we sell is literally the best shit we can find.
We said what is the best blender?
They said blend,
pick,
boom.
We've got a blend tech.
I didn't even have one when we did that deal.
We did it because of these videos where you see a Blendtec blender blend,
a fucking iPhone in a powder.
Why would you do that?
Because they're amazing because they just want to show you how WIC maybe it was
like an old phone.
My phone is dying,
man.
I gotta yeah,
my new one's supposed to be on the way when a five.
Yeah,
I got a five.
Well about time it's the Samsung Galaxy s three sons.
I don't know.
I wouldn't know about that.
You wouldn't know us into the commercial saying what the Fuck Ting you're paying
for these commercials.
Get Brian Read Ben a cell phone but smells a new mood is another product of a on
it.com.
That's a fence.
Fascinating product.
It's a five HTP and l tryptofan product with actually it actually bikes calling
it new mood.
That's like a,
it's really a legit name for it because it actually does change your mood.
It boosts your brain's output of Serotonin.
It has two factors.
Um,
the way it's explained to me with my feeble nonscientific mind is that one is h
five HTP,
which converts to Serotonin and there's also El Tryptofan,
which converts to five HTP,
which converts to Serotonin.
So it gives you a time released effect as it's been explained to me.
But what I do know is this stuff really works.
It's a,
it's great right before bed.
It's just,
it makes you feel better.
Your,
your brain is concocted,
have a bunch of different shit.
And we,
we know that there's certain chemicals,
especially when you're,
you're dealing with vitamins and supplements not dealing with anything
dangerous.
There's no drugs.
It's not an Ssri,
but it has a very similar effect in,
in fact,
a lot of people who are taking antidepressants,
which essentially raise your brain's output of Serotonin.
The doctors tell you not to take five HTP as well.
They tell you that it's,
it's too much of it.
You'll,
you'll literally develop too much serotonin.
What that says to me,
I'm not a doctor,
but it says to me is that you should be,
I have to tell you I'm not a doctor.
I think that's a dollar a joke.
It's it in steel.
You joked dumb.
Um,
which I think it's telling you that you can,
you can get there with nutrition as well.
And I think with nutrition and exercise,
there's a lot of people that fill up shit that would feel a lot better,
David.
Tell.
I'm just saying,
wow.
Put away the cigarettes,
get on it.
Oh.
And,
and it used the code name Rogan and save yourself 10% off the number one
supplement for men or something like that.
Um,
this is my new t shirt.
This is the gas mask.
Chimpanzee higher primate tee shirt.
You can't see it now,
you know,
for the rest of the podcast.
Yeah.
Now you know for the rest of the podcasts with,
fuck,
I'm wearing a,
but we have uh,
three new designs in at higher primate and uh,
there's also,
what do you happen to have now?
It's so funny.
Garner but yeah.
Fuck you want so I knew David towl.
No,
I was going to say,
what's the difference between the Serotonin and the Melatonin?
Melatonin is my puts you to sleep.
Melatonin is what relaxes you and puts you to sleep.
Yeah.
That's great.
Before sleep to Serotonin is what actually makes you feel happy.
Yeah.
Like dopamine,
serotonin.
Because that take you the wrong one.
Okay.
Well you have like a little tip to your filter.
Like a little,
this is a hunter s Thompson for 2012.
You want to shoot ogres out in the parking lot.
I would love to use that for your teeth.
Is that why you do it?
I do it for my teeth and I'm also trying to stop smoking.
So I figured the further I get away from the cigarette,
the more I will.
You need to get a real estate.
I went to smoke it for me and I just do the second hand.
But yeah,
very fucking observant.
Yeah.
We're on top of the ball.
That's not the way it's supposed to say.
We're on the ball.
We say we're on top of the pot.
The bumping it fucking show.
Ladies and gentlemen.
It doesn't start until I heard music.
It doesn't officially start until Brian cues the track.
And then,
then we moved,
move
experience trying my day.
Joe Rogan podcast by night.
Powerful.
David.
Tell what's up my brother.
Welcome back.
Thanks for having me,
gentlemen.
Pleasure.
Every time I come to la I'm always helping.
Like,
can I hang with Joe and we're doing it.
Thank you.
Thank you for doing it,
man.
Um,
you know,
it's one of the coolest things about being a professional comedian is you get to
hang out with other professional comedians.
You know,
I talked to Stan hope once and he was,
uh,
he was drunk of course.
And uh,
he looked like he was Douggie.
It was just got back from the road.
He was like,
you know what man?
He goes,
I could quit standup,
but I couldn't quit hanging out with standups.
That's how I feel too,
man.
I mean,
it's a,
we're so lucky that we have,
I couldn't imagine if I had a deal with like if I had just worked with a bunch
of people who weren't funny and hung out with only a bunch of people who weren't
funny.
Oh,
we drag drag.
Is there anything worst and non funny people?
Well,
I just know that every time I talked to Doug who we both think is amazing,
he's half in the bag and he's at an airport bar.
He's like the lax airport board drunk.
I know in America he doesn't play.
I don't,
but people weren't funny.
Don't get offended.
I don't mean if you're not,
I mean,
if you're not funny and you try to be funny,
that's what I mean.
There's nothing worse than that.
If you're not funny,
just got to accept that shit.
Although that's bullshit really.
Because how the fuck do you ever become funny?
I mean you got to,
everyone was not funny at one time.
I'm a hypocrite.
It's hard because of the phones.
Everyone's on their phone all the time.
So there's like very little connection.
You know what I'm saying?
Everybody's like looking at stuff and tweet.
You think it's harder to be funny today than it was back in the day?
I Dunno.
I think that like for me personally,
my funny stem from a lot of awkward situations where I was like,
how the fuck am I going to get it out of this?
And like I said something and they laughed and then I fucking bolt it.
So I don't know about you.
But that really helped me in my earlier years of like,
hey,
it's going to wrap a sense of humor,
you know?
And then unless she could become a comic,
then you realize there's other guys like that,
you know?
And then like,
you know,
we kind of all gel together and we also have like a perspective on things that a
lot of other people don't like.
A lot of people are looking for like happiness and fulfillment and closure.
And I think as a comic you kind of like roll with the way things are and just
see the humor in it,
you know?
So I also,
at this point,
I feel like I have this a massive obligation to continue to put out material.
You know,
when you got sands and you've really appreciate them and they tell you,
oh my God,
we have the best time.
We love you.
You know,
keep,
don't ever stop doing this.
Like,
wow,
I can't,
I can't stop.
I got to,
I got to work harder because of it.
It mean I used to not believe that when people used to say that,
you know,
that they do it for their fans,
but you really have to,
that's the only way you can do it.
You gotta do it for them.
Well,
how cool is it when a guy comes up to you and says like,
Dude,
I love this joke.
Or like,
you know,
you didn't do that joke that I love and like,
it's like joke that you like and you're like,
aw man,
there is a reason to do this.
Somebody.
Somebody is listening,
you know,
I like that.
Do you still love standing up the art form?
Do you still like watching it?
Well,
you know,
we,
I think we went to this last time.
It's like I don't consider myself an artist.
I mean,
I consider pretty much everybody else.
I know an artist to some degree,
but I very few tools in my toolbox and one of them is midget and Dick Jokes and
that tool is really been used a lot.
So it doesn't matter.
I don't know.
I feel like I'm more tricky than I am like funny and like,
uh,
I do take a lot of chances,
but I don't really,
I don't know.
I feel like after doing a 26 years that I should have it more together than I
did.
I don't,
you know,
Stan hope used you as an example in saying why there was someone not to do
teaching.
Someone was teaching a comedy class and he was talking about how confidence is
like one of the most important things you have to know funny.
And they
use you as an example.
He said,
that is the dumbest fucking example of it.
It's not true.
There's no like hard,
fast rules cause look at a towel,
you know,
brilliant.
Never believes.
I don't believe it.
But you are one of my favorite comedians.
Well I,
I really come at it from the point of like,
I work really off of negativity.
So I think that that's,
that's Kinda like my zone.
That's where you have power.
My,
you know,
uh,
iron man fucking thing in my chest.
So you have to hate even your own act in order for it to work so much.
Hey,
I have to fly in a day early to pick up all the hate that I know I haven't.
What does that cost from,
what does it all go?
I don't know.
I mean,
it's like,
you know,
first of all,
like,
uh,
you know,
it's kind of a great gig if you do hate yourself because you're alone so much.
Like standing in front of an airport chain smoking in 30 degree weather,
uh,
San Francisco,
where it was.
Uh,
there's nothing but like reevaluating your life,
your act,
you know,
the mistakes,
all that kind of shit.
So I think it's like perfect for me,
you know,
I mean,
I don't know how you,
you roll with like a very cool crowd of like excellent fans really.
You know,
you call your own shots and I just look up to you,
man.
I mean I bow to you,
but I probably had to blowing you.
Well that's ridiculous cause too early in the podcast,
one of my favorite comedians is only a few guys that I will go out of my way to
see.
And you're,
you're,
you're certainly one of the,
one of the things that we do different than anybody else is that we go on the
road with each other.
Like we bring,
like if we go on the road,
it's Brian,
it's me.
It's already,
it's Dunkin,
it's Joey.
We bring our,
it's a family.
I just take essentially your family.
So if we go to eat when we go to eat a fucking thousand times a year,
you know it's more than sprite.
Mostly all Fogo de Chao.
Yeah,
we've eaten it up.
Fogo de Chao is in almost every city in the country.
You know those Brazilian steakhouses.
Have you ever chair hit me?
It's the most amazing creation of culinary excellence.
They give you like a little a puck,
like a hockey puck.
Puck looking thing of me.
No,
no,
no.
This is a,
um,
it's like a Chester coaster.
Yeah.
And it's green on one side and red on the other side.
And when it's green they keep common with one of those.
But in Brazil.
Oh,
in Brazil?
Yeah.
It's called a two husker Rhea.
Wow.
And they come,
they come with just fucking skewers of meat that's cooked over open flames.
I didn't know you were.
Oh,
I thought you were like,
you know,
like very organic and you know,
well I eat mostly grass fed meat.
Okay.
My goal is to ultimately eat grass fed meat and game.
I want to,
I want to aim really wild game.
Like,
what will be your ultimate animal to like of all the animals that ever lived
dear delicious.
No,
but there's all the ones that ever lived.
Oh.
Like if I could go back in time and like a dinosaur dinosaur stake.
Could you imagine what a t rex steak would be like?
Like TRX tenderloins or dental wings?
Well,
you can eat alligators and people eat alligators on a regular basis.
Swamp people.
They did all the time for breakfast.
Yeah,
I've had it.
It's not bad.
It's not,
they say it tastes like chicken.
It definitely does taste like alligators.
That's what alligator.
It tastes like evil to swampy.
Just an evil fucking dinosaur.
Isn't it?
An angry monster.
Yeah.
It's like the panda of the dinosaurs.
It was like chill a hundred million years old in that shape.
They haven't changed.
Wow.
So they were,
as they existed more than a hundred 130 years before the big asteroid hit,
the killed all the dinosaurs.
He had already been around 130 million years in this form.
Shall we see them wandering around?
They like the rats of the,
the water war.
The lizard world.
Yeah,
they'll eat anything.
They'll just,
they're monsters.
It's even scary than them is that they got pythons in,
um,
in,
in Florida going through the alligator areas now a while and now the pythons
have started eating alligators.
Tow Shit.
I'd love to see that now.
That would be the ultimate,
it's kind of folk put,
pull it,
pull up the Python eating yogurt.
We've,
we've talked about this in the podcast before because it's just the most crazy
thing ever.
These,
the snakes have no natural predators.
I would have bet on the alligator.
I would've thought so too.
I would have,
I felt no matter how big the fucking snake is,
it's not going to eat an alligator.
Yeah,
exactly.
Does it make,
it's like all just fucking nothing.
No bones.
But they're so snakes are so gangster snakes do not give a fuck up on an
alligator.
He's not poison.
It's,
he's just a rapper.
He rides around,
crushes you and bite you.
That's the point.
You see that,
oh shit,
that's a 20 foot python with the alligator coming out of its body.
Oh my God.
Hail burst through the body.
And the thing died.
Oh fuck that sad thing.
That thing is fucking enormous.
I mean it's really hard to imagine how big that must be in real life.
If you were out there on that wall,
it's,
oh,
it's wide around like a man's waste.
Shit's fucking huge.
That would be the ultimate like Christmas cards to send to somebody you hate
thinking of.
You may have alligators by python.
It's,
we have this weird thing about keeping those fucks alive too.
There's these people in Florida right now that are working really hard to bring
back the crocodile,
the American Croswell what isn't at the alligator.
No crocodiles at different species,
it's more aggressive there.
They have a longer point,
your sound and they're,
they're more aggressive and explosive and one of them just ate a dog in the
keys.
The Florida keys,
that is the worst.
Pull the dog off a dock,
losing a dog to a CROC.
That's probably the word monster.
But in Australia that's going to happen like every three minutes or so.
They have scarier crocs.
They have the big crocs.
American crocs are not that big.
What isn't a screen Australia.
Right.
Really on it.
So you go in the ocean is a great way hanging out.
There's an alley and there's the dogs,
the dingoes.
Wow.
It just snakes.
Yeah,
Australia.
And you going eat live in a certain part of it?
Yeah,
exactly.
The whole middle kind of sucks.
The whole middle is death is fucking the bush and it's just death.
But that what a great place to disappear.
There's gotta be like no cell phone service there.
Yeah.
If you wanted,
if you were like some dude who could survive and you,
you were down with trying to live in the woods,
you could escaped Australia and they wouldn't even go looking for it.
They built it.
Jail Man.
I was in New York during the,
uh,
you know,
hurricane
sandy and we were talking to us a little bit before the show,
but like you got a doomsday prep.
I mean like,
unfortunately I prepped for the wrong dooms day,
but uh,
which one did you prep for?
I Dunno,
a invasion of clowns.
I,
I prefer a good one.
A good one,
but annoying.
Like clowns would be everywhere and we have to fight them off with like water
guns and stuff like that and wrappers.
Yeah,
exactly.
When this was like just fucking,
it was like apocalyptic.
It really was.
That's hilarious.
Ooh,
no power.
Did you expect it to be like that?
It was at way crazier than you expected?
You know,
the thing about New York though is since nine 11,
like our first responders are like top notch.
They really like step up.
They know what they do,
they got plans and all that kind of stuff.
But nobody,
I guess expected like New York City,
a tsunami like wave hitting us knocking out power for like two weeks.
And then there's like Staten Island Jersey where they got it even harder.
But uh,
you take the power out in New York City and you got Somalia basically.
It's just a freaky,
weird,
scary town,
you know?
Yeah.
It's really strange when you see how easy the,
the,
the film that covers civilization can be removed and Pete savage becomes
absolutely arrival.
You really have to worry about survival because the first responders are
excellent,
don't get me wrong,
but they're overwhelmed.
There's just the sheer numbers impossible to deal with.
There was parts of the city where like I was just walking around and it was just
dark and like guys would roll up on you like you can't see him and I'm pretty
good.
Like nick,
no.
And what's happening?
It got to roll up on me and I'm like,
Whoa,
this is like a Chuck Norris,
you know that scene and every Chuck Norris movie.
What was that like in the factory box?
Knocks over.
It was like that kind of thing.
Like just weird,
scary faces.
Just sounds like to walk around a street at night with no gun
gone.
No.
I was like,
fuck,
what am I gonna find him with sarcasm?
What's going on here?
Walking to where you had to go to and fro in your neighborhood,
but there was no lights on for days.
No lights.
It I,
where I lived there was lights,
but when you like we did shows at the comedy cellar,
which is in the village.
They had no lights up until almost the last day.
And we were doing shows to generators,
which is kind of cool in a way but bad cause it went out when I was on but uh,
and went out and all these flashlights and candles started popping out of the
crowd.
It was like that scene in requiem for a dream,
you know that saying like why they're like asked to ask the flashlights on the
check and all that kinda stuff.
So it was really,
it was really a freak show,
but it was a good show.
But when you're walking around the streets you're like,
okay,
this is like,
you know,
what do I,
what can I fight?
Whoever comes at me with,
with a weapon and there's a lot of like homeless people coming off of their meds
too.
So there's like they have like the extra evil in them,
you know?
Oh that's right because they can't get their meds cause there's no power.
So it was like Zombie Style Zombie.
I was walking dead kind of shit.
That's scary as fuck now.
Whizzer a lot of that.
Like we like was there a lot of muggings was there,
a lot of it was right.
There was some looting,
there was some whatever,
but it wasn't like Katrina,
cause I talked to guys who were in Katrina and they're like,
you know,
everybody's like this is our Katrina.
It's like fuck no,
this is like Katrina was like the end of the earth.
That was the end of the world there.
That was like weeks and weeks and weeks,
no help,
you know,
and no power and it was hot and all that stuff.
In New York it was a little bit better than that.
That's for sure.
So I can better than an APP,
but it's still,
it was bad.
She lets you know what can go wrong in the biggest city in the world.
Yeah,
exactly.
When that happens,
when the biggest city in the world gets essentially shut down for two weeks,
that's a real eyeopener.
Oh absolutely.
You know,
like people trying to get into the city and they had to do,
you know,
like buses,
all the trains were like,
exactly like somebody should the Kayak through these tunnels just to do it.
Like I say,
like I did it,
I didn't even think about what it must be like at night with no power.
I didn't even think about it.
I would've stayed inside.
Yeah.
Not have left.
Well,
you kind of,
it's kind of like,
how do you see where you're going?
It's scary.
So unless it's a full moon,
how do you see where you go and exactly.
You know,
the scariest thing I saw was when I was like driving around,
like I was in a cab and uh,
calves by the way,
were like incredibly hard to get at that point.
But,
uh,
there was like a candle in a window of a project and I'm like,
this is what it's gonna look like after a nuclear winter.
Like,
just like one holdout guy in a,
in a project somewhere.
Like,
um,
you know,
like Charlton Heston in the light,
and the Omega man kind of thing.
And you know,
uh,
I was like,
this is it.
This is what it looks like.
You know,
I was it free freak a lot of people out.
But then I think the guests thing freak them out even more.
The fact they couldn't get gas for their generators and cars and shit.
They're online for like 12,
15 hours.
Talked to a friend who said he was online.
It was two 30 in the afternoon.
He had been there since six in the morning.
And you still haven't gotten gas easily?
Easily.
Yeah.
That's crazy.
We never,
we never,
I don't think even the,
uh,
government,
local whatever state thought like there's going to be a gas problem,
you know,
and nobody was ready,
so wow,
you need that gas for the generators too.
So Jesus Christ by bringing everyone down.
But it was good as bad material from it at all.
Oh yeah.
I've got tons of,
I mean like a,
you know,
the whole idea of like,
um,
you know,
basically,
uh,
doing uh,
shows like in New York,
like the top of the line like guys who,
who pulled the most prone are like,
you know,
the hedge fund guys,
the club Dj,
you know,
the male model who's,
by or whatever.
But that week it was all like Renaissance Fair skills like candle maker,
blacksmith,
you know,
any guy who could hook a bike up to a light,
he would get like,
you know,
uh,
definitely at least the reach around that Yukon man show.
Have you ever seen those shows were important.
They have generators that work on waterflow.
Oh,
they take a generator,
they set it up at their camp,
they have a fish camp and they put this generator,
they set it up and then they attach these tubes to it and they stick the tubes
and the creek and the water coming down.
The creek goes through the tubes.
And by the time it,
you know,
it focuses in this one area,
it's spins this thing around and start to generate.
I want that,
I want to get that crazy I,
and he pulls the cord and it's going on.
I've got electricity 1% from the creek
spinning this generator.
So as long as this generator keeps working,
he had his lights on the whole,
the whole thing.
It's crazy.
That really is the one thing that you need is like power.
You know,
it really is the one thing that separates us from animals.
Well we've somehow or another just accepted that that's going to be around,
even though it's only been here for 150 years or whatever the hell it's been.
We were so used to it,
you know,
a million years of human beings and 150 years of power.
We're just like this how we do it.
We've got power.
I could see myself going to my ex girlfriend's house and just hanging out cause
she would have like all the candles and the rural like
candles a girl has is directly proportionate to exactly how long she will cry.
FDF section.
Yeah.
Girls were prepped a little bit harder than the dude's candles.
Mentos you know there's like 30 candles,
that bitch just going to cry for a little while and this petroleum base,
you know whatever girl Shit.
Yeah.
But uh,
we have a lot of different things to help you in survival situation and I'll
tell you,
you know,
who really did not step up for this crisis,
the dogs of New York City because like every other person in New York has a dog,
but it's all these faggot.
He has a little dogs and I was like,
they've been genetically built all the cool like wolf qualities that would have
helped look on.
So they're like,
what,
are we going to do any food there when the snow hit afterwards?
No,
I was already out of there,
but that was like a one,
two punch of like sad
man,
a blizzard.
And the really scary things that they're saying.
Well,
who's the governor Cuomo?
Andrew Cuomo.
Yes.
Yeah.
He's a good guy though.
He seems like a good guy.
He said something really interesting.
He said,
I don't want to use the term climate change.
I'm kidding.
I'm paraphrasing him because it's such a loaded topic.
He said,
but you know,
his father had to deal with in 12 years he had to deal with two major storm
events and he's like,
I've been here for 12 months and I've had to deal with three.
Wow.
You know,
so he's saying like there's,
it's very possible.
Something's going on the,
I think there's definitely something going on that's never happened in New York
before.
Well,
you know,
a buddy of mine,
I,
I assume you know I'm too a big Jay Oakerson yes.
He's a great guy.
Love Him.
Do you know of him?
Okay.
Yeah.
You probably haven't worked with them yet,
but really funny guys toured with me a couple times.
His house was wiped out.
He was like in the flood is flood zones zone a whatever.
I said,
uh,
you know,
it really is weird.
Like when a flood comes at your house.
So I'm lucky.
I like lift up,
you know,
up in that it skyscrapers.
But the scary part about that is like if the power goes out then you're like
Kinda Kinda of stuck up there until like,
you know,
whatever happens.
So you're stuck up there until the water drains out.
Exactly.
You know,
it's like a skeleton,
you know,
basically born.
I believe in the theory that it was a terrorist attack and I think all the
terrorist are now high.
Whether ladies with beards,
Neptune,
Lawton.
Yeah.
Well your first part made sense.
The second part is just like your Hitler cat with a fucking dynamite strapped to
his chest.
I don't know what you're trying to do that.
And a lot of people were just basically milling around a lot of like fires,
you know,
on the street.
Like people make them fires and quick get on the street,
which I
think they should allow them to do.
Why not?
You know,
you keep a sense of a social exact connectedness,
but yeah.
Well it was bad with their food shortages.
A supermarket or a question?
Yes.
Like the first night,
like everybody prepped in terms of like,
you better buy milk and bread.
They always say that milk and bread,
all the uh,
you know,
uh,
which were called French toast that we make.
And then like the next day,
you know,
you're like,
okay,
there'll be more,
nothing.
There was nothing left.
All the people from downtown who didn't have access to food came uptown like a
horde and like,
nope,
no,
a watchman call it,
it was good that they did it because they had no food and they,
uh,
kind of swept through all the Bodega's and stuff like that.
So it was like wiped out.
Wow.
That must've been strange.
Yeah.
I mean like you always assume in America there's going to be food.
You know,
the other thing is the cell phone towers were down,
down.
So even if you had a cell phone,
you couldn't call anybody.
My friend Tommy said he drove,
he drove six hours to make a cell phone call.
You got to just drive around until he could find service.
But it was six hours before.
That's crazy.
Coco had service though.
Did you see the video?
She was posting of her like in the rain with ice teas wife.
She has special bling service.
She had cell phone service.
I said cell phone servers and she has this posting,
these awesome videos of her in the hurricane like rain hitting her while she's
wearing like no clothes and she's like,
oh it's so rainy outside is great.
That's how rap video what tee shirt?
It was entire wet t shirt cause and like Jersey you play dot Atlantic city many
million times.
Right.
I've only played it a couple times cause that that place without power is
fucking [inaudible] next to these terrifying with power.
It really is.
It's a strange place.
Because that whole area around Atlantic city is dark,
scary,
fucking depressed area.
The last thing you ever want to do is be a young black kid growing up in Camden.
Yeah.
No,
I mean that's a,
that's a fucking bad part of the country right now that I have to say.
I don't know if the,
if the governor or whatever told you to like evacuate.
Would you do it?
I mean,
well,
it all depends on how much money you have.
That's part of the problem with some people can evacuate.
There's nothing they can do.
You go anywhere,
right?
I mean we have to accept the fact that there's been a bunch of these massive
events.
Is that cocoa look behind you,
you,
it's,
it's library that is the most ridiculous.
That really is ridiculous.
She
bags of water.
It's like,
look at my boobs,
how wet they are.
That's her tropical storm outfit.
It's crazy.
She must be awesome enough conversations.
I love no wonder why.
I just,
he's always playing video games.
What are you talking about?
Plays video games and he's like,
come over here with this body.
She has the,
you love the body.
I love the fee that fake,
but when I was in Dayton there was a girl really liked that.
I think it's the next boot for real.
She,
this girl in Dayton,
a stripper had a fake butt and it was like the Double D's of fake butts.
It was so amazing looking.
She looked like a cartoon character.
Is that,
what does that affect the way they sent a no,
she stopped really well and she dirt bike ride.
No,
and she left me,
she left me feel them like,
cause I was,
I wanted to see if I could feel it like a fake boob.
It just felt like,
but cause I guess there's so much fat back there,
there's a lot of fat to hide the implants behind.
So it felt like a fake but,
and each one looked like a triple double d boobs,
like a humongous boot.
Like you can put a drink on top of it if that's the latest thing in porno
movies,
right?
Like yeah,
you see that a lot is the fake butts now.
I forgot what they call that.
But yeah,
the baton,
you know,
make it the booty.
A reboot,
I guess you'd call it.
But yeah,
it's been an amazing that the shape of the ASCE has that much of an effect on
us.
It's monkey chinks.
It's more even then like then the personality,
like a girl,
the nice personality and she turns around and I asked is just ridiculous.
Like,
oh my God.
It's like you're like a bay one or what are you like,
Oh yeah,
I love shapely tones round.
I mean that's,
that's what it looked like.
Hers was a little bit bigger than that.
That might be real,
bro.
No,
this is photography that looks like it's pointing that,
okay.
Somebody to shut up that shit now when we were doing the porn show,
you know what I mean?
Joe,
like you were one of them are amazingly greatest guests.
Uh,
we were kind of,
uh,
you know,
I think,
uh,
have difference of opinion with Dave's old porn is a show on showtime and uh,
it's,
uh,
Dave and his friends sitting around watching videos of old porn and you were one
of the ultimate,
you are the Hawkeye of the lesson monkey gives a porn.
You know what you're doing.
You're really embarrassing.
Taja Ray,
you kept throwing that out and I was like,
Holy Shit.
I had to like go through my porn,
you know,
head to find out.
I was like,
excellent.
So thank you.
There was so many and your shows Thursday.
Yeah.
Thursday at 11.
Your episodes Thursday Joe's episode.
Yeah.
This this week.
Joe and Ginger Lynn show toe for some reason.
Joe,
you know her,
she,
well,
she did my first CD.
She did an introduction to this.
A song that I wrote.
Yeah,
she was on my first CD.
Oh Man.
She's very nice.
She used to come around the comedy store all the time.
That's how I knew her.
Well,
she's a very nice person.
Her body,
by the way,
ginger lanes body I think is perfect.
Yeah.
Well back in the day you couldn't get much better.
She was like,
she looked like she was athletic when she was younger,
but she's just,
she was just curvy,
tall,
not too big and she had an amazing body.
Her,
her rack is like,
I guess you could say it's like a B or something like that,
but like it totally fits with her body and her face.
She's just like a little angel.
It was really,
she was a hard,
hardest episode to edit.
She was rotted.
Breaks
not jerking off to you.
I was turned your while you were on the screen,
but there's a lot of hard to do.
A lot of hard work though.
It's kind of a funny show with z.
You have us and the like what we're saying,
we're sitting on the couch and the couch will like grow or shrink depending on
where their genitals are in the scene.
So the cat,
that's what it is.
The couch is like covering the sex organs while they're doing it.
And then we're commenting on the,
on the video.
It was fun,
Dude.
I really enjoyed it.
You of course,
knowing porn.
So while you brought up something that a lot of guys have problems with juice,
which is the male star and not being able to get what you don't like that.
Well,
she told us you don't like it.
She told us what it was about ginger did.
She said they were all coked up.
There's a lot of blow,
which makes sense.
So that's going to be embarrassing.
It's fuck for the guy.
I,
you know,
somehow it all leads to Tony.
What some are calling Lance Armstrong.
Well they shouldn't never use the footage.
It does.
Like there's footage where this guy never gets a hard on and he's,
he's banging her in.
His Dick is like half limp,
right?
Like he's like barely shoving it in and he's like pretending.
It's amazing.
Like you shouldn't,
that's it.
That's a terrible piece of work he did there.
Like that sexy that doesn't get you excited.
It's like getting drunk before you go on stage.
It's like,
can't you just wait an hour?
Yes.
Son of a bitch.
I mean really it is a sad thing.
Well,
it's a fun thing when a guy's drunk on stage and he's having a great time.
Like I've seen crusher hammered on stage killing it.
You know,
I've seen,
I've seen videos of guys pull it off.
Ron White pulls it off,
but it's sad when you drunk on stage you're not doing well.
Yeah,
it's sad.
It's,
Brian is a good drinker.
Ron is one of my buddies and he is like,
he's a classy drinker.
He was like a black belt.
Yeah,
he's excellent at it.
He's a black belt and drinking.
But in the porn world back,
especially in the seventies and eighties,
like,
you know,
blow back then was like considered,
I don't know you,
you said Adderall.
It was kind of the Adderall of our,
uh,
of our time and,
people just did it,
you know,
it was like fun and it kind of got him up and uh,
it's a sexy gig and so they,
uh,
you know,
maybe they overdid it,
but still,
I mean,
hey,
you know,
I'm sure that blow is a lot better than the shit out there now.
You think so?
I,
I have like the real stuff back then.
yeah,
I think it was a lot of pure,
more like,
you know,
that was like the heyday of like,
just powder.
So funny that they just accept the fact that that's going to be cut up.
It's like,
it's so,
coke is so,
it's such a watered down drug.
Everybody accepts the fact that it's been cut up.
Yeah.
Well universal,
you can imagine like you ever watch the show was like,
you know the drug ink,
like when they show the guys making in Colombia,
you know,
and they just chew on the leaves.
Like I wonder what that's like.
I've had that,
I've had that good in a tea form.
They take the,
the those leaves and just make a tea out of it.
Oh,
I,
it's,
it's love.
Very apy.
Gives you like a,
an update.
I didn't like it because what I didn't like about it is I couldn't shut the fuck
up.
And uh,
you mentioned the podcast if you are on that.
Oh,
it would be brutal.
I,
even though it was with Stan hope when I did it,
we did mushrooms.
It was the day of the Iraq war.
It was a,
we were in the desert trip in our balls off and uh,
I was drinking this tea and I drank the tea first and t kicked in,
the mushrooms even kicked
out.
I was like,
wow,
this tea is killing me.
How did you guys even like,
he is like,
amazing this,
he's like the den or whatever.
The Timothy leary of the ship.
How do you guys t how do you get that?
I mean like I got it from a buddy who had just gotten back from Peru.
Peru is the place Inca tea,
they chew those leaves.
You know what's fascinating?
The Coca Cola is the number one importer for coca leaves in this country.
I didn't know that they,
they literally take the coca leaves.
That's like one of the,
the secret ingredients in Coke Cola than it used to have cocaine in it.
That's like one of the big things.
Well it doesn't have cocaine in it anymore,
but it's still,
they still use the extract of the coca leaf and they have like some deal with
some medical,
a manufacturing firm that a,
that takes not manufacturing from extraction from that takes,
uh,
the leaves and takes the cocaine out of them.
So cocacola gets it.
They use it for like the flavonoids or whatever the fuck they use.
That makes it a taste a certain way.
And this company a makes cocaine out of it.
I,
I read this whole article describing how it's all done.
It's fucking banana.
So they have like a special take the fun out of the,
yeah.
What they're going to do with weed.
Pretty sad people.
It's going to say that in Israel they're doing that thing now where they're
taking out all the fun of the weed just for the medicinal.
Why?
Yeah.
Really?
It's like uh oh duels of weed or something.
Yeah,
well they're,
they're figuring out that there's different things that do different things
inside of marijuana and one of them cbds I guess.
And those that,
those,
I dunno,
something else.
It's not the,
not exactly canabinoids it's or maybe it is a cannabinoid,
but it's a non psychoactive one.
But it does.
It helps.
It helps you a different ailments.
Well,
marijuana is like very healthy.
Eat hemp.
Yeah.
Not even hemp.
Like the actual plant itself.
If you could juice it,
if you juice hamp,
it's really good for you.
If you don't,
we're like,
let's say like a doomsday prepping question here.
If you were like in a place where there was only like pot plants to eat,
you could eat them.
Oh yeah.
You can eat them.
They're super nutritious.
That's what I'm saying.
You can make a salad out of them and it wouldn't get you high at all.
Really healthy.
I guess you'd have to try it out though.
Oh,
okay.
Cause that would be kind of cool.
Like a little like pot cereal.
Yeah,
the poor.
Some us soy milk on it or the cocoa.
What's the stuff that you guys are doing here?
Coco cafe.
They sent me,
um,
it's uh,
it's,
it's coconut juice or coconut water.
That would be the mixed with coffee.
That'd be so cool for your kids.
You'd have to be the worst parent or the coolest Marin.
It was like kids time for school and I hear some of your pot coco coffee.
I think it's hard enough being a kid going to school high.
Really delicious dude.
It's go,
it's great,
isn't it?
It's like chocolate milk.
Do you want one of these ma'am?
Oh sure.
That's great.
They sent me a couple of cases.
Where do you get,
can you just get these like anywhere?
It was called Coco cafe.
Oh my God.
It's like chocolate milk.
I like the packaging too.
You know what I mean?
It's excellent.
It's Yummy.
It's very good.
There's a lot of these coconut water combinations that really suck at deck.
Wow.
Some of them are terrible kind of water and vodka is pretty good.
That's why I drink.
Oh yeah.
It was good taste.
But a lot of these companies,
they have shitty tastes and coconut water.
You got to get coconut water.
Like the reason why I see two o's,
coconut water is the most delicious is they get there.
It's a totally different coconut tree.
They get their toe coconuts from Thailand,
from one small place,
one plantation,
and the coconuts,
the trees are short treats and I'm like five feet tall.
Is it totally different tree like you picture those big tall coconut trees.
Those apparently tastes like dog shit.
That's,
that's most people are getting their coconut water from those.
But the boutique places like c two o like c two o there,
they're really cool.
And they send us free shit too.
Um,
and they're,
they have the most delicious coconut water.
It's like very sweet.
It tastes good.
But ultimately you can't fuck with fresh coconut water.
You ever get it?
Like right from a coconut Thai restaurant.
If you go to a Thai restaurant or even some Chinese are wetter,
but you can the law,
I have fresh coconuts and I never knew this and they just split the top off and
it's delicious.
Then you take a spoon and eat the white shit.
When is that again?
The white shit in there talking to me of come.
It's really super healthy for you too.
That will,
especially that water,
that water from a fresh coconut.
It's just,
Oh,
it feels so good.
After you've worked out.
Just delicious.
Yeah.
To this day,
Coca Cola steel imports,
cocoa leaves,
which are used to manufacture cocaine in the United States.
It's not announced anything that you know,
hey,
I'm for it though.
I'm for all legalization of all drugs.
Colorado.
They just legalized recreational pot and Washington.
It was going to be interesting to see what the federal government decides to do
about that.
Yeah.
They step in and decide to start arresting.
I think leave them the fuck alone.
That's a long time ago.
I just let it happen.
I mean,
the problem is it doesn't ever seem like anybody wants to relax the,
in this country.
Yeah.
Everybody's always trying to rest.
There's no,
there's no relaxing of laws.
It's like an acceleration of laws.
Especially.
The other problem is that the economy's down and when the economy's down,
it's hard to tell people,
you know,
we're going to change laws and put people out of work who are law enforcement
officers.
Cause that's what would happen.
I mean if you,
if you all of a sudden made marijuana completely legal and you didn't need DEA
agents to chased after,
we'd have a lot of fucking unemployed people.
There's,
there's a lot of people that they're the,
a lot of rest,
if you look at all the arrests,
there's millions of arrest attributed every year that are marijuana related.
And those all equal law enforcement officers have to work,
you know,
to people to jail.
There's like lawyers court fees,
there's,
there's money to be made and keeping it illegal.
And so that's one of the hardest parts about making anything legal is the money
behind it.
But how has it worked like he live in Colorado?
Okay,
so you want to buy some pot.
So what do you do?
You go to a store,
is there a truck?
You flag it down like an ice cream truck.
You're going to have a certain amount you're allowed to have.
And right now it's the only medical set up in the country that where they allow
the growers to make a profit in California and not supposed to make a profit.
Meticulous.
Yeah.
So in California,
like when you see these big places,
so those are the ones that get shut down because you know,
they're making like x amount of millions of dollars a year selling pot.
Well,
you're not supposed to be doing that.
And when you do do that,
I think the only way to do it is you have to give all the money back to the
community or you know,
make it,
make it so that all the money goes to charities or you know,
funds are there.
There's some sort of a workaround where you get a,
um,
a fair wage from working there and everyone,
including the owner,
would get a fair wage and then the money has to get distributed.
Colorado doesn't have it like that in Colorado.
You could just make money selling weed.
That's how it should be.
Yeah.
That'll be like,
you know,
the pot bearings farming,
man,
that's what it is.
It's fucking farming.
And this idea that it's different because it's a drug that it's so stupid.
There's plenty of drugs available in this country to pretend this country is
anti-drugs is one of the dumbest fucking things ever.
Everybody looks forward to doing drugs and this country,
we look forward to drinking.
It looked forward to smoking.
They look forward to having a cup of coffee and these are all of these are
drugs,
you know?
Yeah.
It's like,
let the people be adults,
you know?
I mean,
there's so much pain and suffering out there.
Might as well.
Like if this,
if this takes some of the edge off of that,
let it happen,
you know?
Yeah.
You're not going to stop it by making things illegal.
You just going to create an industry off of keeping it illegal.
The only way you get people to not do things is through education.
And you know,
whether it's their own personal education,
like if they get to watch people fuck up.
You know,
I,
I've never done coke.
I've never done coke because I watched people who when I was a kid who did coke
and their life fell apart,
I saw it happen.
I was like,
Oh keep that shit away from me.
But
plus you're an athlete.
So I mean like as an athlete you can't do certain things.
Yeah.
Cooks.
It's certainly a bad one.
Yeah.
A bit of butter.
A lot of athletes do it,
man.
Yeah.
Like in the 70s I like a lot of the sports guys,
especially like a baseball,
you know,
hockey,
that's kind of those kind of,
they were like,
they were a racked out on that.
So I'm too impulsive.
I don't trust myself if I really enjoyed it.
Yeah.
I don't trust myself.
I don't want to,
I don't want to have anything in my system that's addictive like that.
Cause it seems like cocaine is very physically addictive.
Yeah.
Heroin's very physically addictive,
right?
Heroin.
Yeah.
I don't,
I don't know about that one.
That one I could see being uh,
uh,
which call it,
they should,
uh,
if people have a heroin addiction,
they should have the needle exchange and all that kind of stuff.
But yeah,
nobody should promote heroin.
I mean,
you can't make it into a cookie.
There's no fine,
you're a musician then it should be a law that you have to at least try it.
Can you imagine if every musician had to do heroin?
Like some of that Babak?
I'm shit out there.
I would have a whole different,
whole different take on it,
you know?
Yeah,
no kidding.
The dog.
Nothing shook up the music world more than heroin.
Marijuana.
Yeah.
I guess I want to shut that up a lot too.
But there was the bands who did heroin had very specific sort of,
they had like a,
an intensity and an emotion and an honesty to their,
their stuff that the bubble gum people,
you know,
if it's weird,
if you go back and listen to like buddy Holly or something like great music,
but listen to like what that guy was doing and then,
you know,
listening to Nuvana listen,
listen to the hip with frank,
Frank Zappa and Alice in chains.
That guy was on every,
I think Frank Zappa was like almost the uh,
you know,
yeah,
it was like a one stop shopping kind of drugs.
I mean,
but he was on cooler drugs too,
like ecstasy and uh,
you know,
I guess,
uh,
Lsd,
stuff like that where the words are the best when you don't really know.
I don't want to say,
but I think he,
when I was 15,
I would listen to Zappa tapes in the church parking lot and just that first time
smoking weed and you're just like listening to his crazy shit.
It was like watching,
it was like virtual acid trips.
That guy is an artist.
That guy was really,
there's no one like that guy
unusual.
I got introduced to him when I was,
I was probably like 10 years old.
My friend's dad was into him.
He was,
yeah,
Frank Zappa and the mothers of invention.
He was the guy.
I remember the dude drove a sob.
She was like 1970 dude had a sob.
I was like,
what is that thing?
That's crazy ass car and he was in a Frank Zappa.
He's just a cool ass dad.
Well that's the whole thing about like this whole now like with rich people,
you know it's like you know how much money the rich people need.
I guess now like the ultimate park has a private jet,
but back then it would have been like a car.
You know,
Butler
and I had obsessive.
I think you look at it like some of these hedge fund guys where they were
talking about,
there was one guy whose wife got some of the bailout money because the bail out
money,
a lot of it was in the form of loans and this guy was worth,
who knows how many hundreds of millions of dollars.
But they showed his house,
they live zoomed in on his house in the Hamptons and it was just fucking,
it's sad.
Huge craziness.
This guy,
I mean you can't even call it a compound.
It was a castle.
He had a castle,
he has a castle in the Hamptons.
See I don't even like that when I go to a hotel.
Like if it's too fancy,
you know,
like a whatever they,
four seasons.
Yeah.
Like I like,
I don't do any,
I don't rate any of that.
I don't,
I know it's not in my ride or anything.
I like hotel or I can do my laundry.
That's what,
that's like the ultimate perk for me.
It's like if I can do my shitty laundry cause I'm on the road so long,
then I feel good.
But there's some hotels where like everybody is like,
Oh yeah,
this is going to get a massage and all that kind of thing.
I'm not into that courtyard Marriott.
It's like a little house,
a little home away from home.
Yeah.
Courtyard Marriott.
That's a good spot.
It's a good middle ground.
Like when I told her with Norton and uh,
already Lang,
you know,
we're on the antisocial tour,
those guys,
I think they like it a little,
like more.
I think they like it better when it's like that.
I just don't like it,
you know?
But,
uh,
we usually all stay at the same place and that's a fun tour because,
you know,
those guys,
they're just good guys.
And uh,
you know,
we're all so old now and uh,
we've all been through the ringer to some degree and Norton is just incredibly
fearlessly funny and rd is naturally probably one of the best comics I've ever
seen in my life.
And,
uh,
you know,
it,
it's just fun to hang with these guys.
Cause now we're at that age where it's just like,
it's just fun to be around guys that,
you know,
and you can just fucking,
you know.
Yeah.
And we please casinos and like,
you know,
it's like our biggest thing is like,
where are we going to eat?
Let's eat.
You know,
like that's a big,
that's a big fun of the night.
You know,
it's so fun going on tour with friends and it really makes it the whole
experience way better.
I just did a San Francisco and Seattle last weekend with Fitzsimmons.
Oh,
he's one of my best friends in comedy.
Yeah.
I love that guy.
And we sprayed,
we had such a good time,
man.
It was so fun.
He is one of the most underrated comics cause his comedy is so,
it's so good.
It's so dry and funny and well thought out.
And uh,
you know,
I know this turns to a big stroke festival comedy,
but if you're anywhere what Greg is touring,
go see him because he really is a great comic.
I like them.
Yeah.
He killed it.
He killed it in San Francisco and Seattle.
It was awesome.
He was really,
really fucking funny.
It's not attack style.
Boston Commons.
Yeah.
We started out together for the summer.
We were like a week apart from each other.
Boston is like turning out to be,
this is the,
you know the,
the generation of the Boston comics,
you know,
you Greg Louis of course.
Nick Depalo.
Yeah.
These are the guys.
Well there was a lot back then man.
It was a very unusual time as far as like the development of standup.
You,
you had one area where you had so many clubs and so many comics in this one town
like you could go to.
I would always amazed,
amazed me.
Like I would go to like Pittsburgh or Philly and I'd be like,
where's the scene?
Where do you guys go?
And you got an Nick's comedy stop.
You've got to have stitches.
They didn't have anything.
Nothing like we had so many places to go.
Like if I knew I like open mic night was a Sunday night.
I knew that if I went to open mic night,
I would see Teddy Bergeron.
I would see,
you know,
Tony v Tony's via all those guys.
They'd be working out,
they'd be hanging out,
they would go up and do sets.
You would see them,
they would do sets on Sundays and Monday nights it would go up at the end of the
show and perform mean it was like a real community of standup comedy.
But it's not like that.
Even there anymore.
It died.
Yeah,
there's,
I was just at the,
at the theater in Boston and you know,
if you want to run around and do other sets,
these really not many places at all.
And if you're starting out there,
I can only imagine how you do it,
you know,
I don't know what happened.
I think that they overdid it because every other place,
like,
you know,
there's the Hooky Lau and the,
uh,
you know,
the place in chickopee like Chinese food,
the restaurants were doing shows that like,
the crowds I guess got baby it or like,
you know,
spoiled and they're like,
there's plenty of comedy out here.
I don't have to go see it.
And there were a lot of like,
you know,
for every good comic there's like three or four hacks,
so I guess after a while,
like,
you know,
uh,
they always say the cream rises to the top,
but you know,
it's a pretty big rise.
There's a lot of guys who would just,
you know,
EC and by what they're,
clapper Joe.
No,
it's interesting though in the beginning there were less bad guys and more good
guys.
If you go back to like the Jimmy tingle error,
Jimmy tingle,
Barry Crimmins,
Tony v,
Lenny Clarke,
that that era,
they're,
they're all killers.
There was like more great comics back then than there were mediocre guys.
Wow.
You know,
when I started out,
I started out in 88 and I got to see,
I've got to see,
you know,
like some of the best comic he's ever like the local guys.
I got to see them like all the time.
There was so much good comedy and that one place there was,
I would say it was one of the rare instances there where there was more good
comedy within,
there was bad comedy
that always got me about the Boston guys compared to the New York I was on.
I hope I didn't say this last time it was on your show,
but they came to New York.
You guys all eventually came to New York and you guys were ready to headline
like almost immediately.
Whereas the New York guys,
like we were like years away from headlining.
Like we were just trying to like work the weekends.
It was a slower process because there was just too much.
Uh,
I guess open mic too much.
you know,
too many comics and not enough stage time.
So you really had to fight for the stage time,
but you guys definitely knew who you were.
You,
you had an act,
you had a perspective and then you,
uh,
definitely,
you know,
came to the scene and made it way better.
It made it way better.
Well,
you know what it was is that Boston guys had a chance to work long sets.
We would do,
we would work for like the comedy connection had a bunch of gigs and Barry Katz
at a bunch of gigs,
all these different people at gigs and there were all over the place and you
would do 45 minutes.
You can do an hour here,
half hour here in 45 minutes here.
So we weren't just doing the short sets in town when I was,
when I went to New York and I saw that everybody would dictate cab and go from
one cry crowd to another crowd doing seven minutes here in seven minutes.
I was like,
that's crazy.
That doesn't make any sense.
Like I'd,
we live for years.
So even when I lived in New York,
I did almost all my sets on the road cause it all my sets in Connecticut.
I was like I can go to do a John Schuler Gig in Connecticut and make 150 bucks
or I could go do a set in the city and make like 10 or something like that,
whatever.
What a danger fields paid the most.
They paid like 50 or something.
Right.
Well like governors,
which is on long island.
That's kind of where I kind of started out.
I just recently was there and the guys who run governors now are so pro comedy,
so pro like supporting comedy,
bringing up new new talent and all that kind of stuff.
And it's really great to see because for a long time,
you know,
like the outline clubs were really just like,
Jersey,
the island,
Connecticut,
you know,
you just went there for money and now it's like this is like a good place to
work out.
Yeah.
Well governors was always really good governance was topline club.
That was always really good.
And um,
the,
the brokerage,
remember the brokerage brokerage pub?
Yeah,
that was a great place.
So there was always a lot of good places to do standup,
you know,
of course,
rascals,
east end,
rascals down the shore.
Rascals.
Such a hearty cause that was a great,
great club.
And,
uh,
you know,
you talk about jersey,
that was like the place where like dice would come in and dom and all those guys
that would come in,
it'd be a big event.
Ah,
yeah.
I don't remember.
It was a go see you guys when I lived in New York
and someone would say,
you know,
hey,
this guy's going to be,
you know,
at a,
at rascals.
Like we would drive wow.
Relays to watch the show.
Yeah.
Cause it was a place where you could see someone do a real long set,
you know,
like a Caroline's or something like that where you get to see them do like 45
minutes or an hour.
Yeah.
Caroline's and Gotham
the big like,
you know,
you get to do an hour in the city and um,
the great and you know,
it's hard on the crowd I think just to some degree because you know,
there's a lot of like expenses,
a parking and food and all that kind of stuff.
But at the end of the day it's kind of cool that you get to see,
like we just worked with Amy Schumer.
She's so funny.
She's so good.
Like I started at Gotham and she fucking rocked out and,
uh,
you know,
I'm going to be playing Caroline's down the road and uh,
you always like it when you get to do a long set in your hometown.
Yeah.
You know?
I love Gotham for that very reason too.
I just,
I never really did many sets at the other places.
I occasionally I would do like Boston comedy or the seller or,
or the comic strip,
but it just,
it always seemed to me like I,
if I could do a long set,
it would be better for my act.
Well,
the seller now has like,
become this like a,
I guess you could call it like the,
uh,
the Alamo of comedy.
Like people come in and they just take a picture of the front because of Louis.
You know,
Louis has like put it on the map and Louie who was probably one of the best
comics ever,
he,
he goes down there and test sets and rock and uh,
you know,
Chappelle when he's in town.
And,
uh,
I guess there's other guys like Aziz and things like that.
So you do get to see like some celebrity comics there.
But the majority of the guys working there are like pretty hardcore headlining,
you know,
top of the line comedy and the people who run it are,
therefore comedy like did not promoters like let's you know,
like turn this into a,
you know,
a website or kind of know cartoon or something.
Well they must feel so fortunate when that does happen.
When you get a place where a bunch of great comics like Louis and Chris Rock and
all these different gun you show up and decided to do sets there on a regular
bank.
So I bombed there,
I'd say every other time.
But uh,
for the other guys it is a great experience at the time.
Yeah.
Cause like I never try and do,
like I always,
you know,
when back in the day when I would go on the road I'd be like,
okay,
I'm back on the city now and I want to do something different.
I want to do different jokes.
I want to like,
you know,
explore comedy,
and that involved bombing to some degree.
So I would,
uh,
you know,
do this stuff that I knew wouldn't work,
but I still thought was funny and the crowd used to roll with that.
But now nowadays the crowds are not like that.
They really want to see a performance.
They want to see it tight.
Like ever onstage sometime you're like,
oh that one didn't turn out.
And you could see in the crowd they like kinda disappointed.
I'm like,
don't worry guys.
The next one will be funny.
Don't worry.
I don't think a lot of people are aware of the process,
the creating new material process,
which involves a lot of risks.
Yeah.
You know,
and they,
they,
I,
I just throw them in my sets and I'll do like Zach knew best way,
just chuck them in the middle and,
and whether or not it works,
we'll,
we'll find out.
But sometimes they don't go well,
sometimes you're not exactly sure what the right,
the right order it is for the,
you know,
the pieces in it.
And like we were talking about Doug,
I saw him
at Caroline's probably like a year ago and he was up there just basically he had
just done an album.
He was in the England,
he was like coming off of like a hardcore tour and he was up there.
I would say he was still in like,
you know,
he was doing his job,
he was getting laughs,
but he also was doing just like some thoughts,
some things that he just wanted to talk about.
And as a fan of comedy,
because I wasn't a comic,
I wasn't Wa,
you know,
thinking I'm going on.
I was like,
this is what I love watching.
Like when a guy's like just thinking it out and he doesn't know where it's going
to go.
And I think that's kind of cool and exciting.
But for the fan,
like especially people who've like,
you know,
they've seen comedy on TV or they like no one person,
then they come and see these unknown people.
They,
I always feel like they're disappointed and I used to get really angry at them,
but now it's like,
I just feel sorry for him.
It's like,
wouldn't it be cool if you've got to see the stones?
Not to equate like what we do to like stones but like them working on start me
up like I think that would be cool.
Well this is the only standup comedy is the only art form where you really need
an audience to perfect the bit.
Absolutely.
They're involved in the creation process cause as they laugh things evolve and
change and as you feel them enjoying the bit,
it's really hard for anybody who does,
has never done stand up to describe that feeling when something's killing.
Like you know the timing you feel where to jump in,
you feel where to let things sit and you really needed audience to do that.
Yeah.
And I always like when you push it past the point of funny to like what the
fuck?
Because then you know the next time you're like,
okay so that's the end of it.
So then next time I'll pull back or you know,
go,
go in a different direction.
That's just my,
I guess process
[inaudible] sometimes you can go further.
Sometimes it's there's different days where you have a different amount of
enthusiasm and and chasing the,
the darker aspects of a subject.
But people don't like dark the way they,
your crowd is cool.
Like they like comedy and they see the funny and sadness in,
in life.
But I think the majority of young audiences who've never failed at anything,
it's kind of like weird when you,
when you do a joke and like it does,
there's not a like a win or a happy ending at the end.
They're like,
aw,
as long as it's really funny.
I think there's less tolerance for self-indulgent angriness today.
Oh see is,
I think people are more aware of what it actually is now.
Whereas before someone would say something shocking and fucked up and people
would go with it and go,
oh,
he's an edgy comedian and now you know,
the majority of people are where I'll know that's just a fucked up guy.
And he's like pushing your buttons by saying something shocking,
but it's not,
there's no real thought behind it.
And he's not really trying to say anything.
He's just trying to make something shocking.
Make it work,
using it as a tool to get a reaction from the crowd and people don't want that
but,
but dark,
great humor.
It's fucking,
it's always funny if it's funny,
it's funny,
it's stands up.
Shit is still sent.
Very dark and very hilarious,
incredibly dark and like a,
you know,
people talk about like,
develop a following and all this kind of stuff.
It's like what does the people who Stan hope are really the,
you know,
the darkest motherfuckers out there and God bless him because a,
he really does not.
He doesn't sugarcoat any of his shit.
You know,
I love him.
His new CD is fantastic.
It's one of his best ones ever and that's what I'm thinking about him,
man.
He always bangs out like a new hour,
like every year and a half or whatever,
constantly working.
It's so important to have a guy like that around
to all of us.
We all like Louie.
It's so important to have a guy like that around a crazy work ethic.
Another guy who every year or so has another hour.
And besides that,
like his crowd is so connected to him that,
uh,
you know,
I feel that his stuff,
it's so personal that like somehow they relate to it in a whole different way
that I can't even understand,
you know.
Yeah.
He,
well,
he,
he develops like different parts of his actual real life.
Yeah.
It puts them in there.
It's fucking a downer dude.
It's got a TV show.
Step it up.
Huh.
People don't like caring about people suffering anymore.
I know.
Right.
And positive energy,
especially since the secret.
But you gotta give comedy a bone for one thing during that whole like New York
thing,
Broadway shut down.
Um,
the big apple circus.
No Way.
The only thing rolling out a funny wise was comedy.
And,
uh,
I thought that was good.
I was like proud to be a comic.
I was like,
the seller was rolling out with a generator there.
We rolling out with generated,
they would close the first couple of days like everybody else.
But then they like what we got to do some shows and uh,
I think Tom Papa was behind that.
Who's another really good guy.
Really,
really funny guy.
And uh,
uh,
this new club,
this stand they would do in shows the candle lights.
So that was like,
he can't get any more renaissance fair and that,
you know.
Yeah.
That's amazing.
I've been on stage before in the power's gone out.
It's weird,
isn't it?
Yeah.
Strange.
Because now you're just a guy talking.
You have no microphone.
You have fun.
Did a whole set the candle light once.
That won't be a cool stage.
I don't have friends that he was onstage and the power went off and it was
pretty clear it wasn't coming back on.
So we just did the whole set to candlelight.
Wow.
Yeah.
I don't know,
man.
It was a little,
my act is so filthy dirty that the romantic candlelight situation does not
match,
feel saying they're perfect.
You know,
I'm somewhere in between candlelight and cross burning.
You know what I'm saying,
like that kind of thing.
I can't fire a campfire and a tarring and feathering.
But anyway,
I have to tell you,
man,
you rocked out on the porn show and I don't want to be a whore and just talk
about porn.
But uh,
you know,
this is the new season and David's old porn on showtime and I got to say that
like a,
you know,
having you there,
it really helped me cause I knew you had my back with the pouring and we watched
some of ginger's greatest cause cause we had like so much ginger Lynn,
you know,
clips,
loops,
movies and like you've got to give it to it cause she's like a,
you know,
she's like I guess you would call like a Delta force of a porn star.
She was out there and like once you got into it she was into it full tilt,
you know,
anal,
three ways,
all that kind of stuff.
[inaudible] homes,
jot home,
she'd Bang John Home Shit.
I mean like,
just like,
you know,
you forget that like in the 80s,
like there's a crossover between like the 70s people and then the 80s and Ginger
and Christy Canyon I think are the Uber Babes of the,
of the 80s.
And I have both of them on the show and I feel like,
yeah,
that's a win.
Christy Canyon was there when we were leaving.
Yeah.
Christy is with Mark Marin and that's a whole different ball game.
That'll be later in the season.
But,
uh,
I just did their radio show on playboy radio and,
it's really cool because a,
they're out there,
you know,
they're still talking the talk and they're sexy.
I mean,
I,
there's a sexiness to him.
I don't know what to tell you.
They still get me,
you know,
going there.
They're hot,
you know,
even though they're a little older,
hey,
we're all older.
What are you trying to say?
I'm just saying that they're fucking a,
you're ready for a Christy Canyon gingerly wish I sent to Chris.
Yeah,
guy.
I've had a crush on youth since like 1986.
You know,
it's just crazy.
But,
uh,
she is like the,
you know,
I don't know.
She's beautiful and had a shot plates.
No,
nothing.
No.
I think that a lot of those girls,
like,
you know,
it was the hairbands and the 80s and then I'm sure a lot of our movie star
[inaudible] guys,
you know,
all that kind of stuff.
Probably Tired of Dick by now.
They were like police.
I think that they're all from me,
some Dick.
And when I was in San Francisco,
Serena who is,
I think one of the hottest women ever to do porn.
She's a redhead,
strawberry blonde,
uh,
Serena who was,
you know,
up for anything man,
like her scenes,
never boring.
And uh,
she came to my show when I was working at Cobbs and it's just cool to hang with
her,
you know,
she's just really cool.
It weird that they're still making porn if you really think about it.
No,
that's not what I mean.
I mean,
that anybody's still near enough to jerk off too.
It's like there's no way you could ever possibly seen all the porn that's there.
It's like buying books and you haven't read any of them.
Yeah.
Like we could have built like a,
a like a,
a seawall with old porn around Manhattan and I've never done it would have been
as dry as a bone.
If you stop and think about it.
And how many porns have been made like [inaudible] and millions of porn.
There's no way anybody who's jerked off to all the porn that's ever been made.
I'm trying,
do you have a specific category that you automatically go to?
I don't know,
talk about a lot of time,
but like I love a amateur casting,
you know,
any era.
But I love it from the eighties and nineties more than now,
even though there's like four or five different,
like a genre is for casting,
but a peer Woodman who's a French dude,
he used to do this thing called private casting and I love his stuff.
And uh,
you know,
if he was in America,
like I would have him on in a second,
even though like,
I don't think I could show any of this stuff.
It's too,
too late.
But,
uh,
I,
I like the retro stuff now a lot more than I used to ever like it.
And you know,
I guess now that's like the new kink for me.
You know,
people love that amateur shit.
Like were,
you know,
they come in for it cause it's like this first time ever and they're awkward as
opposed to like the girl who you lift up her skirt.
She's already fingering asshole training.
Training is just already there and ready to go.
And you know like Oh my God,
this is like the thousandth thick you've seen this week.
This is not special.
You're just doing an act.
Well when we were doing ginger show,
uh,
like just luck of the draw.
We pulled one of her tapes where she did her first anal and we were like,
Whoa,
this is amazing.
You know,
box back then too.
But we both,
you said that you didn't really mind the hair.
Does that turn on me?
Not at all.
It doesn't bother me.
Yeah,
it was,
she's so cute that she could get away with a nice little tuft.
It doesn't matter.
They're hot.
Like you mean if there was like a lot like asshole hair,
too much.
Some grieving if you date like one of those eastern bloc women.
Dark Room ones.
Yeah.
You can only imagine that Iron Curtain Pussy.
That must be crazy.
There's gotta be some hairy bitches up there,
especially up north where it gets really cold.
Yeah.
Like a vampire or something.
The upper legs.
No,
but I would have to say that,
uh,
you know,
now what shaving that a lot of the younger girls or letting it grow out a bit
because,
uh,
it's cool and I think they realized that like,
fuck,
what am I doing this for?
You know,
it's like honestly doesn't have to be shaving shamans.
Weird.
It's a vagina.
It beats everything.
So labs.
Exactly.
Yeah,
exactly.
APPS can hide in there,
but I think what they do is they did the strip most of the girls,
or they'll do diamond,
you know,
and uh,
I think that works.
That's the best way to go.
But you're right,
the anal hair,
that's,
yeah,
you got to bleach that problem.
Trim that out.
Get some illegals in there.
You're good.
Every girl.
I mean it's sort of just universally accepted that hairy legs are disgusting.
No one bucks that trend.
Esther.
Esther doesn't shave your hair longer.
Hair on her legs and my chest.
Wow.
How did she get away with that?
She just wears pants all the time.
Wait a minute.
Are you serious?
I swear to God asked her,
does not shave her legs or armpits,
but when you watch like all these like old school things like game of Thrones or
something like that,
you know,
think about it.
Every chick was Harry disgustingly look hairy.
Like the,
the,
the hot mother.
The mother to the,
yeah.
Yeah.
She's really hot.
She doesn't look like she has hairy legs and now she's not period friendly,
stress it and whatnot.
Yeah.
She's not in the correct.
Uh,
did they shave their legs back then?
No.
No,
not at all.
I wonder when that started,
the shaping of the leg and I think the early 80 soon as someone realizes how hot
it was,
like why fuck when you have legs were really is.
That's the hottest thing ever.
It's a weird thing.
Girls with long hot legs,
shapely legs.
Oh one the girl just shaved like up to the knee high and know like they'll just
shave like what they need and everything else is like this disgusting.
It's hard being a girl.
Wow.
So that's all they can get out of that way.
Hard.
It's hard.
It's a lot of work.
You can get pregnant.
Do you imagine every time you have sex,
all of a sudden it could mean another person's growing inside you fucking drag.
Meanwhile,
guys don't have to think about it.
Love or just our design to just go shoot
him off.
Marlo undeniable impulse to constantly be shooting off loads.
Well here's the bit I was working on,
which uh,
maybe you can help me out with.
Is that the hot load?
You know how guys always assume their loads are incredibly hot,
so do you back away so that by the time it hits it's a Luke warm kind of a nice
feel.
Well if you a cordius you blow on it.
Yep,
exactly.
Shoot a load in their face.
At least you could do is treat it like a,
like a soup.
Take a step back so that there's,
you know,
some of them fire,
the fireball.
Isn't it amazing that you can blow on soup and it actually cools it off?
It's great.
Isn't it amazing that you can blow out hot air or cold air?
You can just go and it's hot or it's cold and like,
how do you change it?
I didn't know that you could do that until right now.
I didn't even realize that,
but he's right.
If you do like,
you get it from like the,
the deep inside your body
is that it's hot.
It never runs out.
You got to keep on doing it.
I could barely breathe,
so I'm going to have to go on your way.
That's totally true.
I know it.
Strippers did it on my crotch through my,
you son of a bitch.
There you go.
Strip club guidance to go all the time now.
Now I feel like a,
you know,
what's the last line you're here?
I don't,
I don't care about like a,
you know,
I heard it.
I heard,
uh,
you were the only person I ever,
somebody told me that you really liked it.
The body shop in Hollywood.
I was there,
went during the fire,
they had a fire there and all that.
Yeah.
The next day they had like this incredible fire,
wait what you say again?
I didn't really,
I don't really like the club but that was definitely one of those cups were
like,
hey you can walk to it.
You know,
like you're all the place across the street from the store.
Like you go play the comedy store,
you want to do something and so you're like,
hey you go over to the body shop.
But I went to like a one or two times and I would say that,
you know,
the girls were really hot but I feel like a lot of them were not like pros.
A lot of them were just like party girls who want to make some coin and you
know,
we went there,
there was like girls I am guys came with us.
So like they were all over the girls and the guys,
you know,
like,
like watching that for some reason I never really give a shit about that,
but um,
I would say it's a good club,
you know?
Yeah.
I remember the,
somebody,
somebody told me you liked that club and then you said like the next day after
going to a burned down.
Right.
The one place that I found that burnt down like me cock sucking it.
Yeah.
It was crazy.
That place was across the street from the comedy store,
but we only went to it like twice and it was the only one,
someone's in town.
I was like,
Hey,
you want to go down to the body shop?
And it was always somebody else's idea.
I don't like places that don't serve liquor,
strip clubs that don't serve.
Yeah.
I would like to have alcohol.
They make you buy to coax.
You don't look at a $9 water,
a bit about it and vagina vagina's and alcohol.
For some reason,
this just as volatile combination in California,
you can't see that.
Like you could have a girl can have a bikini bottom on show your tits and you
could barely keep it together for,
with a beer.
But if you have like actual alcohol and see a vagina,
that's just be too much chaos.
Well that's why I want to go to Thailand at some point.
Cause supposedly they have like the ultimate,
you know like stripper Bar,
Bang,
Gerhard's soapies have you heard us?
Soapies no,
some,
some
guy just told me in Columbus,
uh,
we were there and he,
he said,
uh,
there's these things called soapies where you,
you lay down and I know they put soap all over you and then they get completely
naked and they just like wash your body with their body.
Like they just lay on you and squish around and stuff like that.
No.
And then they dry you off and then you fuck them.
But a lot of time and you pick out load.
When you first get to know there's like 30 people and they all hold up a number
and you'd pick which one you want.
That's for a guy on vacation.
That's,
that's a,
that's a still going on or was that something going on at the Vietnam War thing?
It's still going on.
I was actually looking at flights from,
uh,
Ohio,
like just to see how much it was.
It was $1,200 but you're going to go to Thailand?
Yeah,
but,
but it was a 24 hour flight and I was like,
fuck that.
I'm not 24 hours,
four hours.
That's gotta be a weird feeling because everybody on that plane is a pervert.
There's nobody going.
They're like,
hey,
you know,
I just,
I'm going to University of Thailand.
Okay.
Really a 24 hour flight.
Yeah.
That's like a plank.
It's staying in the air for 24.
No,
I think there was a layover or stopped somewhere,
I think,
but yeah,
that's a weird one.
I've been to Australia,
which is a 16,
I think.
Yeah.
I've never done that flight.
I got to do that at some point.
I've never done one of those comedy festivals in Australia or South Africa or in
South Africa.
That one's fucking amazing.
And,
uh,
the Australian one is like,
how long has that been going on?
Like 15 years.
20 years now.
It's really bad for you.
What the Australian plate.
It's bad for you.
I just did the Brazil one where I went,
uh,
11 hours from Brazil to Miami and then five of us from my,
and I got sick and I never get sick.
It's just like,
why I won't make you sick.
Yeah.
It's terrible for you and you're,
you're constantly around other people's fucking diseased,
coffee,
breath and shit.
And people are spitting and touching things
like being on a submarine,
but there's really no a glory to it.
Yeah.
You know,
it's just super bad fit.
Just something about that research related air to that just really diminishes
you aspire to be better.
I'm flying to stinks and it's getting harder and harder,
Brian.
It's not supposed to,
but I know I saw a special on it that they said that the air filtration systems
in planes are so amazing that it really does.
It's actually really good for you.
Well,
this is what it is.
That air that comes out of those little tubes is actually a very clean air.
Those things be you blow on you that's actually very clean.
However you are in a tube right where there's no fresh air and you are recycling
everyone's breath and that's the problem.
When you have that tube on you the whole time,
well that can help you,
but the,
the amount of air that's in that is limited and it's all being recycled with
people breathing out.
That's the issue is you're,
you're constantly around other people's breath and it doesn't really have
anywhere to go and so there is like a research collation.
There is a filter filtration of it,
but you're still going to take in breaths filled with other people's shit.
There's no way around it.
That's why the fart smell was so bad on airplanes,
someone farts on an airplane,
it's not even like farting in a restaurant.
It's like farting in your face.
It's like it just is no word for it to go.
That's why like when you're stuck on the tarmac for five hours
and you realize like this place,
this plane is built only for the air and like the toilets start backing up and
there's no hair and you feel trapped.
I get incredibly claustrophobic on the plane.
So you know,
once that door shuts I'm like fuck dude,
now I'm now,
I'm in this tube now for the next six,
seven hours.
Huh?
Well it's a part of our job to be on planes and I hate it.
It's not the best part.
But back in the old days like when it was all like just torn like road,
like driving cars,
you and another guy that was the,
you know I've done like a lot of that and there is like,
even though it takes a while,
there was some fun to that,
you know,
it's fine if it's a good comic,
it's fun guy.
I did a lot of main gigs with a lot of Boston guys.
We did a lot of driving up to Vermont and shit like that.
Four and five hour drive.
So it was great.
It was a lot of fun.
But now everybody is so like,
you know,
PC and all that kind of stuff.
It's like it,
let's stop and you know,
go apple picking.
There's really no,
like,
there's no like adventure to it.
Yeah.
Like nobody,
I want to pick up Delft,
China set for my mom.
I'll go on tour with you.
You feel like you're the last of a dying breed?
I'm self destructive comics.
Yeah.
It's kind of hard to explain to the new guys like the road to them.
You know,
like a lot of them like I hate the road.
I've done two gigs.
I'm like too,
and you hate it already.
You've got to be about 10,000 before you get that real good hate of it,
you know?
Yeah.
Joey Diaz and I have been on some fucking adventures across this great land of
ours.
That guy
been on the road like before,
I dunno.
Before the road.
I mean like he must've started out working like state fairs and shit like that.
I mean he's,
he's hardcore.
Yeah.
He's like that Johnny Cash song.
The highway man done this and other lives.
He's done this.
And other of,
he's like me,
he's probably more comfortable on the road than he is ever at home.
You know?
Cause I never feel like at home I'm like,
ah,
Joey's most comfortable I think on stage.
Oh,
okay.
You know,
I think he just wants to,
I think he just loves getting out there.
Yeah.
He's just a hustler too.
You know,
Joe,
he's always got something going on.
Yeah.
Well that's the cool thing about it man.
It's like,
you know,
uh,
this,
the good thing about comedy is that like,
you know,
every day is a new day,
and like you can,
you know,
it's really up to you to make it happen.
And everybody's like,
if I only knew the right guy and if somebody read this screenplay,
it's like,
yeah,
but that's not about comedy.
Comedy's about like getting funnier.
You just getting out there.
Really.
That's,
that's what I tell them.
Everybody's like,
how do I meet an agent?
I'm like,
why?
So some guy can not take your calls right now.
You're doing more for your career,
going on,
doing seven minutes and this Douche bags going to do for you ever.
So you know,
at the end of the day it all becomes about that engine,
the engine that propels your life as you,
your work,
your,
your comedy that you create.
And everybody is wrapped up on getting auditions and getting a show and getting
a series and getting all these things,
which ultimately are not the best thing for your,
your standout.
Yeah.
No,
it hurts your standard sitcoms kill you.
You're on a second,
right?
It's like the,
did you feel funnier and you have to get it now?
I felt less funny first I had of work long hours.
You know,
you were on the set long hours a day and I got lazy and I stopped writing
material and all and there
was no encouragement,
you know?
No one,
no one thought that the produce even said it to me once.
Like why?
Why are you still doing standup?
You're an actor now.
Yeah.
I hate when they say that.
So crazy.
But,
but it's great money and that,
so that's why everybody wants to do it.
But ultimately the real money's in standup.
I mean the real happy money because you're,
you're doing,
which actually enjoy being on a bad set of you ever been on a bad side?
I dish and for every,
I think that's a calm that never made it.
I don't even do acting like that's like the least thing I could give a shit
about it.
I'm like in my late forties now and I'm like,
dude,
I could give a shit if I ever get on the Big Bang theory or any of that stuff.
I know guys are like,
I follow me.
I could get on there.
And I'm like,
you know,
I'd rather be able to say what I want to say when I want to say it,
where I want to say it.
Then for low money,
then be on a sitcom where I walk out and it's like,
watch out fellas.
It's time for break.
You know like some stump,
some line that has been overwritten by a bunch of guys.
I don't know.
Sitting there in the writer's room,
you know,
so maybe I'm a dick.
I Dunno.
It's just never,
it never,
it never excited me enough to be do that.
And like I always was like,
peg,
this the guy,
I like the setup to the funny guy and I hate that,
you know,
like,
what are you doing Waldo?
And then he would say the funny line that'd be like,
Wham,
wham.
You know,
we were,
I think a lot of comics sort of led in that direction in the 80s when you saw
like Roseanne and Tim Allen and these guys go to have series and Seinfeld and
these series make millions and millions of dollars.
And so that became like a direction where everybody was sort of like thinking,
well,
I,
I guess I got to do that.
I guess I've got to do that.
Um,
and then the idea of just being a standup was like,
nobody appreciated that.
Nobody was like,
oh,
he just wants to be a stand up.
They'd be like,
why?
Why,
when you can do movies.
Why?
When you can do a Sitcom,
why wouldn't you do a television show?
But they're awesome guys who are like legitimately like,
you know,
I'm a standup but I'm also an actor so I give it to them,
like not down,
but like Seinfeld who was really a standup,
who became an actor went back to stand up.
So like that's what he does now.
He does his standup.
Roseanne I think is like so creative,
you know,
like all over the place that she could do stand up if she wanted to.
But I think once you make that TV money and then going back to stand up,
you feel like you failed but you shouldn't because it's like it's fun and like
you should see the fun in it,
you know?
Well it's,
it's sort of like the only art form where you're expected to transition and turn
from a caterpillar into a butterfly.
True.
Whereas if you're a rapper,
nobody's expecting you to go into movies.
You might,
it might go into some movie.
Most,
most rappers just essentially stay rappers.
And that's where people love him.
Well,
but I think all the rapper guys,
they want to be like an action hero,
you know,
like kinda guide in the,
in their head and then,
you know,
cause I don't think they're making that much money rapping anymore.
Nobody makes any money,
you know,
off to cds.
Yeah.
Often tour though.
On towards where the real money is.
But yeah,
I think they definitely want to and they have incredible rapper confidence.
They're like always so confident,
you know,
sense confident,
you know the opposite of comedy.
Yeah,
exactly.
You can't have like a a guys self hating himself as he blows away.
Dude,
we're only 47.
You can have your blog.
Okay,
that's true.
There is some,
there was a racial thing too.
It's a cultural thing.
Yeah,
exactly.
You know,
it's very different.
That's why like,
uh,
you know,
I would say that comics who do sitcoms and I know a lot of them who did sitcoms,
when they come back to the comedy,
they're always like,
you know,
I'm a little rusty.
I'm like,
are you really?
I mean it's just like you should've done stand up the whole way through.
You know,
and it wouldn't have been that way.
I know a lot of guys quit.
Kevin James Basically quit.
Really occasionally it goes on and does he shows with a Ray Romano.
But once he started acting just a really doesn't have the time for it and he
does a lot of movies too.
A lot of uh,
like kids friendly movies and that,
that to me would be the worst to be like in a kid friendly movie.
And then you have this dirty filthy act,
you know like I think it happens to Tracy Morgan a lot where they seem on 30
rock,
which is like a,
you know,
it's a smart,
funny show and then they see him live and he is just fucking out of control.
I did two Kevin's movies.
I've done a zookeeper,
which is a family friendly movie.
And then I did,
here comes the boom,
another family friend.
But I played myself in that one.
Okay.
But you know,
Kevin has been my friend since we were like,
we started out.
It was a great comic tone.
Yeah,
very funny comic.
That's why it kind of bums me out.
But he doesn't do it that much.
Yeah.
A lot of people don't even know.
I started with him on Long Island and he like always knew who he was a well east
side and governors and t uh,
him and his brother who also has a comic Valentine,
they were there all the time and uh,
you know,
but Kevin was Kevin and ray,
they kind of like,
you know,
are like soul brothers in a way,
even though both of them are the widest guys and they kind of the same comedy,
you know,
it's like very,
it's endearing.
I don't want to offend anybody then when a family,
but it's still like raise comedy is still really so well written.
Like,
you know,
from what I remember from the past,
I don't know,
he did a one of those um,
Kevin and bean does,
they do an April foolishness show in la and he did it I think two years ago.
Oh Wow.
He was great.
Yeah.
He should be on the road.
Cause he's funny guy,
man.
You know,
he's got a lot of kids and you know,
it's the mirage every now and then.
Hi,
they human Kevin do like gigs together.
And I think he was doing a new show,
but it was like a drama.
Right?
Wasn't he doing like he was,
it was a,
I'm not men behaving badly,
but men of a certain age.
So it was uh,
uh,
executive produced by Michael Royce who,
is a guy I started doing comedy with and he's a great guy.
He worked on Louise First show on HBO.
He's worked on ratio.
He's a great writer and a,
he was a comic too.
So,
you know,
how did you get from stand up to this idea of doing porn?
Showing old?
Was this your idea?
Yeah,
this is my idea.
And a Stuart Bailey who is the executive producer of the show,
we,
uh,
we pitched it to another network and they said no,
and uh,
you know,
they,
we made the pilot with them and this is years and years ago now.
So,
uh,
they said,
no,
uh,
but it's too dirty,
but it's funny.
And then I went over to showtime and that's what we did.
And it really is kind of like you did it.
It's a two dimensional show.
It's me and the comic ragging on these clips.
And like basically just Dick joke in and around unscripted.
We didn't script anything.
And then we go right to,
uh,
you know,
the tribute part of the show,
which is bringing out the legend or in some shows I bring out young porn.
So it's like the last show of the season,
I'm going to give it away.
Now we've got like asa,
Akira,
Jesse Jane,
Caden Bras,
Shawn Michaels,
who's,
uh,
one of the coolest dudes ever to do porn,
you know.
Uh,
he's black,
but he,
he is so cool.
And,
uh,
he,
it's really weird for the dude's important,
especially like guys like Shawn Michaels.
You got to give him a tip of the hat because like,
you know,
they are definitely,
you couldn't have porn without them,
but yet they don't get any of the credit,
any of the money that the chicks do.
So it was great to have a guy like there,
uh,
like that on the show and he's so smooth and so just like charming and
interesting.
And then Andy Dick was on the show and Adrian Currie,
who is really,
really cool.
It was like guys check sober.
Andy Dick was sober and he was a little disappointed because I didn't have much
retro gay porn,
but I did the best I could.
And there's a lot of retro gay porn out there.
It's just,
I wasn't sure what the network would think about it.
You know,
guy on Guy Peter North,
there's a funny one because I'd love that famous four loads.
Yeah.
Famous for giant loads,
absolutely loads.
It's pretty ridiculous as that guy's loads.
Oh,
amazingly.
They like,
uh,
just whatever it is,
a banana clip he has on the bottom of his dick,
just like 50,
60 loads in there,
Joe.
That Zma shit really has affected my loads.
It's humongous now.
Zinc and magnesium,
it boosts your testosterone and makes your loads more frothy.
So that's the cool thing about you guys show.
It's like helpful tips,
you know,
like Doctor Oz stuff.
We're trying to spread a little positivity there.
David towl.
We're trying to enrich the world.
We're trying to power up people,
get them excited about life.
God dammit.
But the dude up dude
do porn like a Ron,
Jeremy and Jeremy Have Morris.
We have him coming out.
Herschel savage.
Uh,
who else?
John Holmes job homes.
Not here.
I'm just saying how Ginger Lynn was very proud of the fact that John Holmes
always got it up with her.
Yeah.
Because that was the thing with John Holmes.
He had this giant rubber Dick.
A lot of times it'd be like half hard,
but with her she's like,
he was always excited.
That's good.
She was very,
very proud of that.
Yeah.
I would like to,
she's a real,
she's a real trooper.
She feels like she was proud of her work that wasn't just like punching in at
Wendy's.
Exactly.
She was doing some art.
Yeah.
And uh,
you know,
with,
with the,
with the dude's in the porn,
like there's so many great ones.
Eric Edwards,
um,
who I didn't even know he was into it,
but if we do it again,
I'm definitely getting him on it.
Uh,
Randy,
uh,
w w oh shit.
What's his name?
Up and comers.
You know what I'm talking about,
Randy Blah,
blah,
blah.
He
no,
for op and commerce series
a,
you know,
uh,
he used the one to Bang Jenna Jamison.
I bigcommerce number 11.
It's probably one of the best known scenes in a,
in uh,
in porn.
So,
oh,
up to getting them on.
You're talking about Jenna's first one.
Randy.
I forget his name,
but he's not a good looking fellow.
I think he's going to look it does know.
Very big deck.
Seems like a nice guy.
He's like a regular guy,
good guy.
And a,
you know,
like I said,
Peter North,
uh,
Joey Silveria,
he's,
he's a fucking,
he's a genius.
He's great.
It must've been a weird time for those guys.
That eighties porn.
Cause there was no,
there was no real seventies porn.
I mean,
it was so rare.
It was like,
you know,
you had deep throat and behind the green door,
whatever it was that,
that movie,
yeah,
behind the green door,
whatever it was.
So anyway,
thank you.
So I mean,
all of a sudden these guys come along in like the 1980s and it's just crazy
porn.
They become stars v.
It's the VHS era.
Like it was a,
the world that didn't exist before because the porn that was done before that
literally had to be streamed as a movie.
You had to have a project was the movie.
Nobody had a fucking projector and they're gonna go reel to reel and Ugh,
too much nonsense.
But when a VHS tape came along,
changed that game,
you can just stick that sucker right in the VCR,
which everybody had in the 80s everybody started watching porn and there was the
whole section that you would go to at the video.
I remember my mother was very upset when that came out.
Like,
oh,
this is just right here.
You had a great first point story.
It was like,
you know,
I asked,
everybody comes to the Chicago,
like,
what do you remember the first time you saw porn?
That's like the big end of the interview.
I'm not an interview on Charlie rose or anything,
but your,
your story was interesting where you said like,
you were at a buddy's,
you went over either a buddy's house or like you just found his porn or
something like that.
And it was like an uncomfortable situation.
I don't remember it,
but it wasn't,
it was a very good story and a,
you know,
I'm going to turn it into a animated series.
Awesome.
Everybody's first born.
I mean,
uh,
I remember finding porn in the woods,
like magazines.
We both talked about it.
I was in the scouts and there would be like fucking,
well,
I lived in Florida and we,
we lived near this.
Uh,
I lived near a in Gainesville,
Florida,
and it was
really,
I think Tavaris from there.
It's a lot of alligators around.
There is a lot of woods when we,
we'd go out in the woods,
me and my friends,
we'd find like snapping turtles and shit.
We'd make slingshots and we would always find porn.
Always.
It would be wet bags of porn,
like a plastic bag talked under a log.
You know,
we found a bunch of that shit.
It's weird.
And went from that.
That was the only way you get it.
It's magazines,
you know?
And Dude's always had to be half hard.
They couldn't be fully hard.
They had rules like you couldn't have a full heart on.
So scene after scene would be this girl who's like pretending to be in total
moaning,
ecstasy,
spreading her pussy apart.
And the dude would like lay his dick on her like a drowning victim.
You know,
I was like this poor like dead Dick.
It was like,
what?
What is the message here?
I think it's so important for young kids to see magazine porn cause it really is
it.
First of all it's an adult,
but it's not like real porn.
So it's not like you're not going to blow his head out.
You know?
It's kind of like just enough.
You know what I'm saying?
Like,
it's like a,
it's like the training wheel on,
you know,
it gets you started.
Yeah.
Like you don't want your kid to immediately go into like high fi wifi download
porn,
you know,
it's like,
here's a magazine,
you know,
it's hustler.
It's great.
Take a look.
You know,
I remember feeling that you'd get when you found a hustler,
like,
Whoa,
you'd be peop,
you know,
turning the pages.
Oh Man.
Jerking off to just reading the art,
reading the jokes,
drip of saliva from his tongue to her dick.
Go like,
what the fuck am I?
This is crazy.
She's sucking to suck his dick.
She's going to do it.
Well,
the cool thing about the girls today,
and I know we're talking way too much about porn,
but I appreciate it.
It's very few places where you can talk about porn.
So,
uh,
we,
we had Joanna Angel on and Rob Zombie and Judah Friedlander to do this,
like horror porn.
And I have like the worst horror movie porn.
It's like,
you know,
they'll good titles I couldn't get rights to.
And the ones that I have are just like joking,
cheesy,
fucking bad porn.
But a Joanna who is like,
you know,
super hot punk chick,
tad it up,
really cool.
And a great business woman by the way,
she runs her own company,
makes her own films,
you know,
she's watching this point and she's like,
this is horrible.
Like this is like you don't shoot Dick that way.
And it was cool to get her perspective on it such as director,
you know.
But uh,
you know,
I was like,
wouldn't it be cool if like a,
you know,
they could redirect these porins like to today's standards.
I think it would be almost impossible,
you know?
That would be a good idea.
It really would be cool if they could like whatever that is,
you know,
I'm exited or something
porn.
Did they,
they're not,
they don't like every loop.
It a lot.
They get a lot of like Debbie does,
Dallas is,
and they did a,
you know,
they've,
they've done the same movie like over with different people.
Yeah.
Once they hit,
I like a theme that works like deep throat,
sore throat,
sweet throat.
They do like a million versions of it,
you know it is different if you watch the old porn compared to say like there
they are definitely better at filming shit and showing you more and better
angles and stuff.
Like a lot of the old porn was like a little awkward.
He couldn't really see what was going on.
They like what looks good and what feels good is two different things sometimes.
And so sometimes like someone has to like turn sideways and they're having sex
and like an angle,
like a sideways angle just so they could show you the genitals better.
Whereas they didn't really do that nearly as much in the old days.
Brian's leaving,
he's got the shit,
he's got to go jerk off.
It just went totally.
He can't take it anymore.
He's calling it a pest but a,
it's going to be,
why is going to rub it out?
He's going to bang went off.
But I think what the old porn that,
uh,
that doesn't happen
today is that you have a lot of guys who did old porn that were really actors,
you know,
and that day that the old porn was like to pay the bills at today.
Like you have a lot of guys who were just like everything and they do porn,
you know,
like uh,
uh,
personal trainers,
they're all these different things.
They all want to be actors I think.
I think at some point everybody wants to be an actor who does porn because
they've got an amazing confidence to be able to fuck in front of other people.
That's like,
just like balls.
You know,
something happens.
I think to a lot of people when they first come to la where they have this idea
that they're going to make it in show business that might be an actor.
And then they came out here and they see what a process it is.
They see the,
the,
the infinite field of gears and machines in front of them.
They're going to have to get ground through before they pop out on the other
side.
And some people just,
they lose,
they lose hope and it pretty quick.
Yeah,
that's the thing man.
It's like all those people who were like an extra on like an ed show like 18 or
something like that.
I'm always wanting to like what happened to that guy?
What happened to this chick?
You know,
like where are they?
but I assume they were around in La,
you know,
just making it happen and you know,
just trying to get day to day built a bill,
whatever.
Yeah.
Isn't it funny that when you used to be someone famous and then you aren't?
It's sad.
But if you see someone and they were never famous,
it's not sad.
No.
If it's a trauma,
regular guy with a regular job at a Deli,
you never get sad when he see him.
But if you went and you know one of the guys from different strokes is in a
deli,
you'd be,
you'd feel sad.
I used to get that all the time.
And you know,
I'll only say this to you because I think,
feel like we're both,
you know,
the same kind of boat here.
It's like after I stopped doing the insomniac show,
people used to come up to me all the time and go like,
what happened and Blah Blah Blah.
And I was like,
well,
we were just done doing the show,
you know,
and like,
they're like,
how could you ever be done doing TV?
You do TV forever.
And to some degree they're right.
But I'm was also like,
I don't want it to be cheesed out like where it keeps going and going and going.
And people would be like,
you know,
come and see me live.
And they were like,
you know,
like,
oh,
this guy's a failure in show business when they,
in my head,
they don't know that.
Like I could give a shit about television.
It was really about being able to do stand up because I did stand up before the
show,
during the show,
after the show.
And that was really my dream.
Like if somebody said to you like,
Dave,
you can never do stand up again.
But you can have a shitty reality show.
I'd be like,
fuck you,
I'm not going to do that.
I mean it's like I love,
I love the ability and freedom of doing standup and there are a lot of people
that think you're a loser though of yes.
It's their dream.
It's there and mine wasn't canceled so it was just like we're,
we're done doing it.
I mean you get tired of doing that show too because people are constantly trying
to get hammered with you.
There was that,
but there was also like the real like,
and I'm,
I'm pretty business like you know when I work it's like w it was getting harder
and harder instead of easier and easier to get access to things outside of bars.
Like you know,
working late stuff.
I'm like really just cool.
Like events.
Like we would either get there like a week late a week early
for folks who don't know.
INSOMNIAC was a show that Dave [inaudible] central on comedy central was really
cool.
He would do his show and then he would go out and you know the nightlight,
he's an insomniac.
You'd go see what the fuck's going on.
I really am an insomniac.
And the sad part about it is being,
you know,
I don't drink anymore.
So it's like being up for three days,
editing porn and like having to do radio and all that kind of stuff.
There's no fun in that kind of up,
you know what I'm saying?
But uh,
you don't like doing radio?
I love doing radio one.
It's somebody like you or like,
oh and a stern like where I get to like just talk about other shit and just be
funny.
A lot of these stations that they have me on sometimes like the soccer mom
stations,
there's a lot of stuff you can't talk about.
But then there's also like,
you know,
they want jokes,
like when I do Bob and Tom,
I love doing those guys because they are older dudes.
They know porn,
they know all the porn things and like,
you know,
there's definitely some standards there,
but it's,
it's not,
I can work with it.
I love it,
you know?
And I like being able to be,
I'm pretty good on my feet,
you know,
I could talk about a lot of different things going on in the news,
whatever,
politics,
all that kind of stuff.
And I,
I like that it's,
it's exciting and it tests me,
but when it's all about like,
you know,
you did this and like,
give us a setup for,
uh,
you know,
the football game and shit like that.
I don't like it.
You know,
there's not that many really good radio people.
That's why the podcasts are cool.
A dozen or so in the whole country where you look forward to him.
There's a few guys and different radio stations where you go,
this is going to be a fun show,
but a lot of,
a lot of bad uninterrupted meaning you guys in San Francisco,
they gay guys,
they're great.
They're amazing.
And Johnny Darr,
who we call who I call Johnny blaze last time I just did his show,
he is so,
uh,
he's cool because Johnny knows the porn people,
he knows the business and he's a lot of fun,
you know?
So I think it's great that,
uh,
you know,
yeah,
he has a fun show.
Can't say Johnny dare shout out.
There's a bunch of good radio still Kevin.
And being in La still one of the best.
Yeah,
it was just,
you know,
it's a dying market.
It,
the radio is slowly getting absorbed.
Don,
when I say a dying thing,
what I mean it's like that morning fun personality that really Howard Stern
invented that's not that common anymore.
Like that slowly being phased out by these Jack FM channels and can sort of
shows and people that,
you know,
quite honestly,
they don't really have that engaging a personality.
They just know how to keep things moving along and sound like a radio host.
Play the right songs.
Well let's take a quick breaks.
You would know better than me.
What does that,
that computer that tells him like,
you know,
they can tell when people aren't listening and listening.
So they have that.
They kind of like stifled by that.
So this probably a lot of cool dudes who now have to kind of like suck the man's
Dick to keep the show on the air.
And it sucks my man,
willy and less Willie.
And in Denver,
uh,
the,
the thing that they try to do when you try to put a formula to something,
you can't put a formula to something being entertaining.
And the only way you find out if someone's entertaining.
So you've got to let them be themselves.
And when you start fucking with this and tweaking that and changing that,
people that are PR people that are creative understand what's going on there,
that it's a stifling sorta put the people that are uncreative,
they just trying to fix it there.
So we're just trying to make more money with this.
We're just trying to make this a better radio show.
Well,
we need a girl.
We need a sidekick.
The numbers show a women don't feel represented on your show.
Like you just,
it's got to be good.
It's gotta be entertaining.
And the only way to find out if it's good or entertaining is to someone's
actually them be allowed to create the show.
It's like,
it's gotta be the vision of one or a couple of people.
As soon as you start adding producers and noncreative people in there going to
fuck it up,
it's going to fuck it all up.
There's no way around it.
Every show I've ever done where the show wasn't doing well and the producers
came in and the executives came in and they had notes,
ah,
let's fucking notes were terrible and they ruined everything.
Well,
you know,
like you said,
it's got to be someone's vision like Ron and Fez,
these guys like I listened to them,
you know,
and like they definitely have a point of view or perspective and there's like
definitely a chemistry with the people in the room there.
So it's,
it's,
it's intriguing to watch.
Same thing with,
uh,
you know,
Nick Depalo and Artie Lange.
They've got a sports show on and like sports,
unless you're hardcore sports guy,
you know it,
it's Kinda,
it's Kinda hard to listen to it,
but they do like a fun show about sports and both of them who I respect the most
as comics and is just cool dude.
It's cool that they got to think together and they have great,
I guess you could say like back and forth chemistry.
So
depaulo is one of the most underrated comic.
Exactly,
exactly.
Amazing.
Depaulo was one of the guys when I was a starting out,
I was like an open mic or nick was already in it a couple of years,
I think one or two years and he was already solid.
He was already working.
And I remember he would be the first guy,
he says,
big fucking muscular foot fucking guy.
Yeah.
And some mother fucker would a full head of hair and I was like,
oh,
you can look like that and still be funny.
Like I,
you know,
I thought you had to,
be like awkward or stranger.
He,
he,
his stuff is so well written and it comes at it from such an interesting
perspective for Boston guy.
Like you always feel like he's a true Boston guy,
but his stuff is like,
so,
uh,
sophisticatedly fucking evil.
I love it.
And you know,
hungry and yeah,
like pure anger,
true anger.
And the,
I always find that's like the ultimate funny,
like just like somebody who's like really fucking angry about something,
you know?
I like that.
So the world needs more angry comedy and Nick Depalo to check him out because
he's fucking cool.
And uh,
you know,
there's a whole bunch of young guys coming up now that I work with who I think
also have the same heart and soul of these.
Like,
you know,
Jay Jay,
Kurt Metzger.
I'm very funny.
Like Vicky on Kurt has some of the funniest shit I've ever heard.
And uh,
you know,
he's just now working his way through the system.
But you know,
I took,
I worked with him in Nyack at the,
uh,
levity live.
That's a great club,
by the way.
What did that used to be?
It's in the mall.
So it was,
it was imax or something.
There was a Gig in Nyack way back in the day.
I wonder if it's the same gig but levity live is like does the same boots that
do standup live in Phoenix.
I couldn't fill it out.
I couldn't fill it up but I brought uh,
to the big place.
It's probably like 500 seats and I'm making these big giant places now.
Yeah,
but do you like it?
Cause you could definitely feel that kind of standup live in Phoenix.
I loved that.
Loved it club that I've ever done.
Like it felt like it felt like a club but didn't feel like a theater.
And I liked working downtown Phoenix and everybody used to play the Tempe
Improv,
which is fun.
But I like downtown Phoenix cause that's like the heart of the fucking,
you know that the town is that,
that's a hardcore town.
Crazy town.
Yeah.
So you get like a whole different crowd now.
It's not just college kids and that's a wild west town.
It is.
Yeah.
You can carry a gun.
There were better.
Don't realize how nutty Phoenix is as a town.
We were in Scottsdale.
I'm never told the store on the air before,
I don't think,
but we came out of a club once and there was all these people laying on the
ground.
It was really weird.
Um,
a guy had gotten his key from the valet and he was hammered and he just plowed
through this line of people sent people flying through the air and we came out
like literally seconds after it happened.
And it was so strange because it was just eerie silence.
We walked out and it was literally seconds after it happened and people were
lying on the ground shit and the car was stopped and no one believed what they
had seen that this guy had just stomped on the gas and ran a bunch of people
over,
send some people fly in.
I believe people got like seriously,
seriously injured.
I think people might've even died from it.
It was,
was that,
it was,
man,
I guess it had to be the early two thousands.
Oh,
like 2000 2001 it was when I,
I think I first started doing the Tempe Improv in the late nineties,
so it could have been around there too.
It could have been like 99 maybe.
That was a great club.
That was very close.
That was one of the best.
I'm going to play the DC Improv and I think that's the best improv in the
country.
The improv in DC,
Irvine,
NTC are probably the last two really great ones.
Three is very underrated too.
I couldn't fill it.
Couldn't fill it up.
How dare you.
I know.
I felt bad.
You know why I love the people.
I didn't know if they knew they would be,
there would be seniors.
That's the thing.
Fuck Outta here.
That's the thing about this social media stuff.
It's like,
it allows people to know where you're going to be.
Uh,
I think it's the beach crowd too.
I Dunno.
I always blame it on like,
you know,
like it's near Huntington beach,
so it must be like,
you know,
the surfer people didn't come out.
They didn't connect with you.
I had never,
like I never do any more excuses except I will ask what,
what else is going on in town and if it's high school football and you're still
not selling out,
then I'm like shit,
I better fucking call a cousin and get a job doing something because this is
dude stop it.
You just need to get more active on Twitter.
It's just podcast.
Yeah,
podcasts would be great or let us know anytime you have a shovel,
a tweet it for you and I were just talking.
We got to do like,
I just want to hang out and do a show with you.
I would love to do that.
I would love,
this is not about money.
It's just about,
I want to like get in front of your crowd.
I feel like your crowd would get my shit immediately.
They love you 100% and I went down,
step it up.
I would not walk through the show.
I would get to my age.
I believe you would have just a couple of midget jokes and you know whatever
Obama.
Either way,
man,
the people that listen to the show would love to see you wherever you are.
So just tell me where you're going to be and I'll tweet it.
Well,
I'm going to San Diego this weekend and I don't even really know the club,
but uh,
I'm looking forward to it cause I have San Diego comedy club or is it the other
one?
Oh Shit.
A comedy madhouse.
I think it's the mad house supposedly.
Great.
Yeah.
So I'm into doing it and I'm going to be selling days.
All porn shit there too.
So,
or a shirt or
some booty shorts.
See I guess on that.
There you go.
So I'll be doing that shit.
So I'll be hanging out.
It's more that people don't know you,
man.
We lit a service we offer here at the Joe Rogan experience.
We use my Twitter and like we sold out a,
Brian counseled out Philly really in advance.
Another great week in at helium.
Yeah.
And he's never done that before.
He said it was just from,
from Twitter,
putting it on Twitter.
I had to Columbus sold out shows because
it's um,
you guys did the man,
you are the king makers.
Well comedy,
but we've figured out a way to get through the fence and now we're just letting
other cool people through the fence.
I'd find a hole.
I appreciate it was speaking for the other comics.
We appreciate what you do and anything that helps.
Good,
cool people come see really raw hardcore comedy is good,
is good for the industry.
It's good for the comics and it's also a,
you know,
let's face it,
it's a,
we're in the,
nobody has money so you might as well just come and you know,
check it out.
Well it's worth doing.
Standup comedy in its best form is one of the most entertaining things in show
business.
In my opinion.
If I had a choice between seeing a great comic and seeing anything else,
movie a band,
I would love comedy over all those things like as a,
as an art form and then in an easy to get right.
It's not easy.
We all know a guy,
a lot of guys we don't want to watch.
We all know,
a lot of guys,
we walk in the room,
we see him on stage or wonder out of there.
That's how the audience feels too.
So when we find something that's good,
we promote the shit out of it.
Well now
doing it over 26 years,
I've never appreciated more of the people that get the comedy.
Then now like,
you know,
back in the day it was like,
the drinking party Frat guys,
now it's like any,
they're older now,
they're all married,
they bring their wives and they're like,
what the fuck is this kind of shit.
But I really appreciate the comedy fan who gets the jokes and like sees like,
you know,
hey dude,
I saw you with Mitch Hedberg and Lewis Black on tour and like,
you know,
that was the best tour.
And you know,
I love Mitch and all kinds of like that kind of shit.
Like I never get tired of.
So you know,
I've gotten,
I've gotten it a lot from people who've seen you.
They'll like,
you know,
her,
you on the,
on the uh,
you know,
on Rogan's podcast and it's really cool to hear you guys,
chew it up about the comedy.
So there are definitely a lot of comedy fans out there.
We just need you guys to like fucking come to the clubs.
Yeah,
well they just need to find out where you're at.
I guarantee you that's a big part of it.
There's a lot of people that are huge David tell fans they just wouldn't know
that you are going to be somewhere.
Yeah,
you gotta be real because only one way.
It's like to really reach people you,
you got,
it's got to be a social media thing.
You have to have a website that you update on a regular basis.
You have to have Twitter and not about flyers and that doesn't really only in
parking lots or hire a guy flyer for a couple of hours.
Flyer on my car yesterday.
World famous psychic,
I should give out a number on the air.
Should I,
that was one of the funniest things I ever saw.
An airport security was a crystal ball.
Like somebody who was trying to get a crystal bone airport security and then
they took it from them.
And you're like,
the joke,
of course,
the easy joke.
Didn't they know that they were?
No,
but I mean honestly that was hilarious.
What did they think?
It was still
kind of bomb a neutron EMT blast fucking space.
Paul.
Yeah.
Inside there.
A lot fucking explosion.
And I'm in Indiana.
Indianapolis.
Holy Shit Dude.
Some house exploded.
Most likely a gas leak.
Oh,
shit happen sometimes.
Uh,
it happened was another one on my message board.
A guy was saying that a one happened four miles from his house and he said he
could feel the blast on his chest.
Holy Shit.
From four miles away from his house.
Yeah.
Oh,
hey.
There it is.
Like when you see what,
what it looks like,
that ain't shit.
You got to see the overhead.
There's an overhead shot.
That's unbelievable.
It doesn't even make sense.
Look at that man.
Like a drone strike.
Look at that.
It looks crazy.
Yeah,
it looks just like a drone strike or like some sort of a missile strike.
Go to go to images and uh,
there's a one large photo of a,
an overhead image where it shows,
um,
there's one of them right there.
Click on that one.
All right,
here's a video of it.
Oh yeah,
but go to the,
go to the images just cause there's,
there's one image that's so insane.
It just,
you can't even wrap your head around how big the explosion was.
Yes.
I don't know if that's it.
Yeah.
Oh Wow.
Wow.
Look at that.
Fuck Dude.
They're splinters there.
Then we'll reduce the splinters.
The houses fucking exploded.
What a heartache that must be like,
how many do you see your house?
It's just fucking,
or people for road.
Yeah.
Zero.
Well that's something that we have to remember is that we have fucking gas
pumping into our houses.
It's amazing.
Right?
Doesn't happen on a regular basis.
It's like a gas stove.
Before I got both.
I got to go to these other stuff.
But uh,
Scad,
another shoe to do it.
Yeah.
Sorry Dude.
I really,
because I can stay here for fucking nine hours and it would never get boring.
But,
uh,
what is it going to say?
My house,
I thought I had a gas leak so you know,
I get the handy guy to come in and he's like,
uh,
well first of all you don't have gas.
And I'm like,
you sure about that?
And he goes,
yeah you don't.
So then I'm like,
why do I have this blinding headache?
You know?
Cause that's what I thought because it with gas,
like you always thinking like,
oh you know,
like they always tell you dizzy,
blinding headache.
And I'm like,
Oh okay.
So I'm really just basically on deck for a stroke.
You know,
I went through the normal luck kid.
I was like,
it's gas,
it's not me.
It's like,
oh no,
my brain aneurysm,
something's going to happen.
So you sent the guy in cause you had a headache and you
smell gas.
I buy please fucking reeks of just,
it's horrible.
So I mean,
do you live in New York?
I live in Manhattan,
so you know,
what's the address?
Okay,
cool.
Yeah.
With apartment.
I live in battery park right near the memorial.
No,
uh,
it was a washed out.
Now it's an aquarium.
Yeah.
No,
but I live a,
you know,
in the,
in the city.
So I figured it was like,
you know,
they're on gas or something like that and it turns out there's no gas there.
And I was like,
Oh shit.
Okay.
So then this is just a,
my neuro something,
uh,
you know about to be,
I'll be eating,
you know,
baby food next time,
you know.
[inaudible] yeah,
some of it will be open the hanger.
Do you live in the thick of it where you look,
look out your window,
you see nothing.
My skyscrapers,
everything is,
skyscrapers is,
there's no good view anymore.
You've got to be like Donald Trump to have a view where you're just like a deck
and you just laugh,
you know?
But everybody wants to be on the,
on the park.
I never,
never got that whole idea.
I like,
you know,
like I like being in a place where I can get in a cab and like get to the
airport because I'm a comic.
You know,
it's all about like getting Adam and Adam,
which is impossible now because the mayor shut down all these streets and like
there's bike lanes,
there's like,
you know,
unicycle lanes.
There's like,
you know,
skip to my Lou lanes.
It sucks.
So this is post hurricane you mean?
No,
this is like been here last two years where they made it more like walking
friendly and in Manhattan,
honestly,
you know,
it's like you just,
it's so hard to get around to begin with.
It just made it impossible.
Is it the only city that has cabs like that?
Cause I've never been to a city which dominated by cab.
So a Manhattan is,
I mean,
I can't think of another place that's so strange where they've just decided to
like,
look,
you can't park.
Forget it.
Don't,
don't even try it.
Just let us take care of you.
Well,
the cool thing about living in Manhattan is that you don't have to have a car
because it the subway and then there's cabs and then his bosses.
Yeah.
But you learn all these other people drive for you all the time.
But I mean,
I mean come on,
it's not like a limo.
I mean,
you know,
you're some guy from Senegal,
you got to trust this guy around.
You don't even know this guy.
True.
You never know when that goes to car.
Well it's also,
it's a weird thing.
You constantly interacting with all these other people like in close proximity
and cabs.
Well that's why I like going to Minneapolis because it's like the widest town
with the most African cab drivers,
boy soldiers,
you know,
they brought him over there and like they're all cab drivers and you know,
they know the town pretty well cause they're pretty into not going back to
wherever the fuck they're from.
So they're on it in New York.
The guys are like,
Eh,
one year where the,
the shot like 48 cab drivers in a year.
Oh right.
Yeah,
that's right.
It was like a cereal.
Wow.
Really bad.
They were robbing cab drivers.
So they would take,
and that's one of the reasons why cab drivers would stop picking up.
Urban's really stopped picking up the urban kids blank.
Um,
they would,
uh,
they would take them somewhere and they would just shoot him in the head and
take all their money.
Wow.
It was really common.
Like I believe it was like 48 was like the record one year and it was pretty
spooky for these fucking cab drivers,
especially those gypsy cabs,
you know,
there's a lot of people that are operating as cab drivers that had like
different licenses are no licenses and they're just sort of sneak out of rides.
Undercover Shit.
Yeah.
If you mean you could just sneak around and give people rides.
We got that in England.
A guy give us ride wasn't even a cab driver,
but those guys give us a deal.
Don't they have to go to like cab driving school there?
They have to learn the knowledge.
You know,
they have to like learn all this England.
Yeah.
I don't know it,
I know they do.
They have to like go through this incredible,
there are also like are their father was a cab driver and their father's father.
Yeah,
kind of bullshit.
When we were in,
um,
I think it was in Manchester with my friend Dave Bishop.
We got a ride with some dude who was just a,
uh,
illegal cab driver.
I was like a lot of illegal cabs because there's not enough regular cabs.
So there's like these dudes who like have a little navigation systems like you
need to run.
Okay,
I got Ya.
All right,
20 bucks and you're like,
negotiate with them and just hop in his car.
It was like a fucking Toyota Tercel good idea.
Yeah.
I think it's pretty common.
I think it's illegal though.
I think they can get in trouble if they do it,
but it's like there's so much demand for it because there's not enough cabs
huffily porn pornstar start doing that since they're going to all be at a work
site.
What is the deal now how the porn stars reacting too?
For folks who don't know,
there's a,
Brian said they're going to be out of work because they just passed some crazy
new
out of work.
It's just that they've made it a lot more annoying.
Now they have to go outside of La county to do porn.
They can go to the owl condoms.
Yeah.
Yeah,
they can,
they have to all go out.
But a lot of these girls,
California state wine,
no,
it's just Los Angeles County.
So all you're going to find it,
it just made more annoyed and more porn stars are going to be late to set and
it's going to,
I don't know,
when I do the Avms,
I'm sure that I'll,
that'll be like a,
a topic or something like that.
But they will keep making porn.
They'll keep losing money,
making porn.
There'll be more like,
you know,
illegal download it pouring,
all that kind of stuff.
So it's a lose lose proposition all the way around.
And then making it a,
you know,
well explained to people don't know what it is,
what we're talking about.
Well I don't really,
I'm not from here,
so I kind of know they have to wear condoms.
It's prop B,
which was a,
I think it was property,
but uh,
it passed.
And what what that means is they have to wear condoms now.
If they're doing a blow job,
they have to have like the,
the mouth condom.
They if,
but what sucks is they had all these hidden things built into it.
Meaning like if you're married at home and you want to go on my free cams or
whatever your Webcam,
Webcam show,
do a Webcam show,
you have to have a permit that costs up to like something ridiculous like
$60,000 just to do that.
Just that form with your own wife,
Webcam.
So there's like all these like hidden things that they put in there on top of it
and everyone knows that aids is not real.
So yeah,
well yeah
Dr Peter Duesberg but we are not really,
we really shouldn't be saying age is,
well you know there's things about,
the thing about making porn now it's like there's such little money in it.
Like I think a lot of girls think like I'll just do porn for a while and that
that'll be like this amazing amount of money and then I'll go off and do other
things.
But porn is like,
I,
I'd say it would be like working like the Maitre d at like a fancy restaurant.
You're making that kind of money but you're doing it in like an afternoon.
But like,
you know,
instead of work in a whole week,
you're going to make that much money and they work scene to scene unless they're
a contract girl and the contract girls probably make some more money and they
also get a lot more publicity.
But unless the girls actually,
uh,
control their image and own their material,
their chances of making the sizable amount of money,
which they're due by the way they are definitely do money.
Uh,
it's very low.
And you know,
I think the industry itself is going through a big transition about like,
what are we gonna do?
How are we going to make the network for us?
Cause it definitely works for the people watching.
You know that,
I mean,
there would be no internet without porn,
you know that.
Right.
Well it's an interesting thing the way it happened where they all of the sudden
didn't have an outlet to make money anymore.
Yeah.
Just like no more DVD sales.
They completely went away.
I still buy DVDs.
The last guy.
Yeah.
What do you think,
what does the drop off like how it was an enormous travel,
cause I used to have a lot of porn producers.
Um,
the,
a lot of guys used to come to Jujitsu.
Yeah.
I used to train at John Jock's place in the valley and they uh,
they were rich as fuck.
They had these big ball in cars and,
and those guys,
a lot of them lost their houses,
got their houses repossessed.
Those really common
I think important to people live for the moment.
So there's probably a lot of guys who have money but they like want to show it
off kind of like rapper type.
Yeah.
And you know,
they think the money's can always be coming an end and like,
you know,
might as well buy that car and like a boat.
And then a lot of girls also live kind of high high up there and you know,
now they realize that like,
you know,
I really should say,
well at least the girls still getting some money.
Right.
The guys,
the producers,
that shit's done,
man,
it's over.
I don't know how they make money now.
I have no idea who's making money and how it's being made.
I know that there was a big buyout on a lot of these companies where now they're
all kind of under one flag and that,
uh,
it's good and bad for porn where like,
you know,
a lot of,
a lot of these independent producers have been bought out.
Hopefully they made some money,
like a.com kind of thing.
But I doubt it.
And uh,
you know,
now it's someone else's headache,
the whole like,
you know,
how you get it out of the distribution,
all that kind of stuff.
So it,
it's an interesting business because,
you know,
I don't know much about the actual making of the porn.
I just know about the licensing and all that kind of stuff and that a lot of
these titles,
you know,
it's a very gray area,
in terms of like who owns what,
uh,
who can show what.
And at the end of the day it's all going.
I ended up on the net and people are just going to watch for free.
So you know all that money you're spending for a lawyer when you realize you're
like,
ah,
you know,
is this worth it?
But you want to be on the up and up and you want the business to make money.
And I do,
I really want,
you know,
this show is about [inaudible] not only the old point source but making it a
cool place for young ones to come out and show everybody that they're funny and
cool and they're just,
you don't need seem naked without them being interesting and that,
you know,
it's great for comics to roll with this kind of shit since we all know the porn
and uh,
it,
it's,
it's kind of like,
it's very important for me that the show works for the industry,
you know,
like,
and uh,
at the abns when I meet the people that go,
Oh,
I love the show.
I love what you're doing for pouring.
And I never really got it,
but now I get it.
Cause it's like it's a place for the people to see them do something besides
fuck
yeah,
I seen them in a positive light to exactly.
Yeah.
It's a weird thing with us with morals where we absolutely down on porn in a
strange way.
Yet it gets seen and used by so many fucking people.
If you look at the numbers,
the amount of people that are involved,
uh,
in watching porn is fucking staggering.
The amount of porn downloads at supposedly 40% or somewhere around there of the
Internet's entire traffic allied.
Yeah.
So what's crazy to me is that that industry,
when,
when the internet boom
came along,
that industry was essentially dig gutted,
took the legs right off of it.
The,
the industry fell apart.
People were completely out of the business.
People lost jobs like crazy.
But those jobs were never deemed to be legitimate.
So there was never any talk of a bailout.
There's never any talk of government assistance.
But Chevy's,
okay,
we have to save Chevy.
Chevy is important.
Chevy makes cars.
We knew we can't lose Chevy jobs.
And so they went in to save Chevy or GM,
but they didn't do shit about the porn business.
They just let it die.
They,
they'll always be pouring in.
They'll always be a porn business,
but they are scraping by bank bailouts.
Absolutely.
Porn bail outs,
no fucking way.
I don't even know how they do it.
Like I don't know how they looked at backers.
Do they,
you know,
it's,
it's like,
uh,
you know,
just some money they found like from jungle gold digging,
I don't know how they do it,
but has there been a business that fell apart?
That's that big of a business that was a dead almost completely evaporated in
such a short period of time.
The,
besides the music business,
I guess point of music and also to some degree,
I guess the comedy,
like,
you know,
comedy is,
Oh,
I don't think so.
I don't think comedy's really been affected by it and negative way.
I Dunno.
I tend the downloads and all that kind of stuff,
you know,
it helps us.
I think it gives,
it,
makes people want to come see us live.
I hope so.
I think there's for artists,
I think it switched to a live performance model for for uh,
rather,
uh,
music artists.
But for porn,
man,
what are they going to fuck live?
Maybe that's what I should do.
They should have live fuck shows.
This was a stony.
Yeah,
they would,
they would be doing it.
Why don't they do have a live fuck show?
Why can't like wouldn't you pay money to go see Danny D on Mon?
Fuck Brian.
They do live 10 black guys.
They have sex shows all the time.
Then I in Columbus was telling me no but legal.
That's not yet pit bull fights.
Alright.
Yeah.
Now that we've deemed who the champion rooster is,
some guy who,
you know,
holding on with a hot chicken is arm holding up a gold bar.
I got my money on.
I think they have that though in San Francisco.
Legally.
I don't think so.
They have that.
They do things there.
They would spit on dildos and shove him and yet he and gloves.
Man,
I,
I can't thank you enough for having me.
I love you.
I love talking to you too,
man.
Please let us let us promote your gigs coming up.
People want to know about them and I want to tell them,
so let me know anytime you're anywhere,
I guarantee you all these people on Twitter there were saying yes,
yes,
yes to that right now.
Well,
I'll be in San Diego,
but when I get back to La,
if you're doing anything around town,
let me know cause I want to come out and just,
you know,
if five minutes we'll do it.
Listen,
when are you going to be back here again?
We'll schedule a show here at the ice house.
I'll be here through the whole whole whatever.
We'll work it out.
We will work it out.
It'll be good.
He doesn't want to come in on their relationship.
No,
no,
no.
I,
it's like I don't even have a schedule.
I understand.
Um,
ladies and gentlemen,
we've got a,
we got a crazy week coming up.
Let me tell you about the dude we got tomorrow.
I can't wait.
He's,
he's at robotic sky is a bunch of books about robots.
Uh,
like pretty much taking over the rural and stuff like that.
Were born to robotics robot apocalypse.
I think Robo apocalypse is,
um,
let me,
uh,
let me get his,
his,
his information here.
He's a Daniel Wilson.
He's a young guy and he's got a phd in robotics and,
uh,
he's,
he wrote Robo Apocalypse,
which is a novel about a robotic insurrection against men,
basically like a terminator type movie that Steven Spielberg is going to turn
into a movie,
but he's a technology expert.
We're going to talk about military robots,
privacy issues,
artificial intelligence,
the future on how long until we start incorporating robotics technology into our
own bodies.
It's going to get freaky.
So that's tomorrow,
Ladies and gentlemen,
and they will probably do Eddie Bravo on Wednesday.
It's all about,
uh,
when I can set up this,
I'm,
uh,
having some work done at the studio.
So thank you to Matt stags,
the official death squad,
a publicist for hooking this up.
He,
and he's a very cool motherfucker and the host of the,
um,
disendow podcast.
Uh,
as well.
And I'm a publicist author,
right Ray,
cool guy.
Matt's tags because you an author,
I don't know.
He's an author of emails because emails are very well written thanks to David
[inaudible].
Jen would follow him on Twitter,
a towel,
a t,
t e l l on Twitter.
It's at a hotel at a towel.
Dave's old porn or just old porn on Twitter.
But most importantly a tell to send him some love.
Ladies and gentlemen,
let him know you love him.
The guys,
he's adult porn I don't show is fantastic.
It's,
it's a really,
really funny show.
I enjoyed doing it.
It was fucking really fun.
Thursday.
Yeah.
Showtime this Thursday on showtime a ting.
Thank you Tim for sponsoring our podcast.
Go to rogan.ting.com and save $50 off any of the android devices.
Some bad ass phones there.
No contracts.
Cancel anytime you want.
Tell the big boys these big networks to go fuck themselves.
God dammit.
I'm so this weekend we will see you in Montreal.
That shit is sold out.
You dirty bitches.
But there is a death squad show.
Is it here Friday night,
a Friday night,
I hear and in 12,
12,
12 at the American comedy co in San Diego.
And who was in here?
Who's here?
I don't know.
Yeah,
I'm putting it together right now.
Okay.
And 12,
12,
12.
I will likely be there for that,
but we don't know yet.
I got a lot of shit going on bitches.
I'm busy.
Yo.
Um,
thanks to a on it.com go to [inaudible] and it and use the code name Rogan and
you will save 10% off any an all supplements.
If you use the code word Sandy,
we will take that 10% and donate it to hurricane relief.
Um,
we uh,
decided to go with the Salvation Army because we find that,
um,
in this instance they're giving 100% of the donations to,
uh,
to hurricane relief where some of them,
it gets down to as low as like 30%.
That's kind of important.
Like when you know how much of your money actually goes to the,
to the,
not to the infrastructure of the charity,
but actually goes to help.
Um,
higher-primate.com is my tee shirt company.
There's new t shirts and this is the monkey.
A gas mask chimp by Mike.
The macro.
Well,
yeah,
Mike Maxwell did some bad ass art work on this.
It says Higher Primary Department of Health and welfare and a,
we also have another new one that he just designed.
It's fucking amazing.
I can't wait until that one's gets released.
And a couple of shirts that he designed a that were based on posters for a
Chicago Gig and uh,
Atlanta Gig with Joey Diaz and Duncan Trussell.
Alright.
I talked too much.
It's official.
I'm tired of hearing my own fucking voice.
Got dammit.
Mad.
Love to all you ladies and gentlemen out there in the Twitter verse in the
universe.
We appreciate the fuck out of it.
Every one of you,
all the positive tweets and all the cool people that we meet after shows.
It's a,
it's humbling.
It's overwhelming.
And it,
uh,
w we never get tired of it.
We appreciate the fuck out of all of you and we're doing this for you guys
officially.
It's,
uh,
we will never stop.
We will roll on.
We'll get through this together.
Rise.
Lacey,
she had them in rise and evolve.
You are not the person you were yesterday.
You are a accumulation of your experiences.
Be the hero in your own life.
I love all you bitches.
See You tomorrow.
Okay.